Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 30. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe, in der sich immer alles um die Wissenschaft dreht. Manchmal im näheren, manchmal im weitern Sinne. Und so auch heute wollen wir ein Thema aufgreifen, was in gewisser Hinsicht sehr aktuell ist, es geht um die Gesellschaft, es geht darum, wie die Gesellschaft miteinander umgeht, miteinander klarkommt und insbesondere wie sie ihre Konflikte austrägt und wie gut es gelingt, das unter Kontrolle zu bekommen oder auch nicht. Und um darüber kundig diskutieren zu können, begrüße ich zunächst einmal Andreas Zick, schönen guten Tag.
Tach hallo.
Herr Zick, Sie sind Sozialpsychologe, stimmt das?
Nein das stimmt nicht so ganz. Ich leite ein Institut für interdisziplinäre Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung und ich glaube ich darf das nur leiten, weil ich interdisziplinär orientiert bin. Ich bin gelernter Psychologe ja, ich habe promoviert in der Psychologie, habilitiert in der Psychologie. Habe auch Professuren vertreten in Dresden und Jena,
bin dann aber berufen worden auf eine Professur für Sozialisation und Konfliktforschung an der Fakultät für Erziehungswissenschaft in Bielefeld. Bin dort sofort kooptiert worden von der Soziologie als Mitglied und zum Leiter gewählt worden eines interdisziplinären Instituts. Im Institut arbeiten wirklich alle verschiedenen Disziplinen so wie es gerade passt und ich sehe auch in der Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung das ist eines dieser exzellenten Felder, wo man interdisziplinär denken muss. Das geht gar nicht anders. Da ist die disziplinäre Verortung manchmal hochinteressant und wichtig. Wir brauchen Soziologinnen, Soziologen, Psychologinnen und Psychologen, aber wenn es um die Phänomene von Gewalt geht, Radikalisierung und so weiter lösen sich die Disziplinen auf.
Und insofern wir sind auf dem Weg, transdisziplinär zu werden, aber damit habe ich mich auch beschäftigt, ich glaube da sind wir noch nicht.
Was ist denn transdisziplinär?
Transdisziplinär würde bedeuten, wir arbeiten in Forschungsprojekten so zusammen, dass wir auch auf der begrifflichen Ebene Neuentwicklungen haben, die jenseits der disziplinären Verortung liegen. Das haben wir versucht mit unseren Forschungsprojekt zur gruppenbezogenen Menschenfeindlichkeit. Das geht ja auf ein Konzept von Wilhelm Heitmeyer, dem Leiter vor mir, zurück. Wir haben daran gearbeitet, was ist Menschenfeindlichkeit? Das übersteigt die Disziplin. Das ist nirgendwo disziplinär richtig einfach zu verorten. Aber da geht es auch um Methodenentwicklung. Das heißt Transdisziplinarität versucht dann immer auch Methoden neu zu organisieren und vor allen Dingen auf der Ebene der Arbeitsorganisation versucht man dann eben, Arbeitsgruppen so zusammenzustellen, dass man diesen interdisziplinären Nutzen erheben kann. Also ich habe mir das sehr genau angeguckt, als ich angefangen habe am Institut. In dem Bereich der Gesundheitswissenschaft gibt es in Amerika viele Versuche, Transdisziplinarität herzustellen durch Arbeitsorganisation, Kooperation und Koordination. Da sind wir in Deutschland noch ein bisschen hinterher finde ich.
Also um das mal begrifflich kurz einzuordnen, als Interdisziplinarität bezeichnen Sie die Zusammenarbeit verschiedener Disziplinen?
Genau.
Aber die Transdisziplinarität ist sozusagen der nächste Schritt, dem verschiedene Disziplinen auch an gemeinsamen Begrifflichkeiten arbeiten und gemeinsam forschen.
Genau und auch neue Disziplinen schaffen. Also wir haben ja die Exzellenzinitiative in Deutschland, die versucht so etwas auch zu motivieren. Ich könnte mir zum Beispiel vorstellen, dass die Gewalt-Konflikt-Forschung ein eigenes Feld wird. Das sieht man immer an der Art und Weise wie der Nachwuchs Karriere bauen muss. Wenn die Leute bei uns arbeiten, dann kriegen sie ihre Credits, aber in den Disziplinen. Also wenn ich Karriere machen will, ich wäre zum Beispiel nie auf die Position gekommen, hätte ich nicht die Kriterien in der Psychologie erfüllt. Aber nun bin ich in einem Feld, wo mir als Leiter auch für den Nachwuchs andere Credits wichtig sind. Das heißt man könnte sich vorstellen, dass Gewalt-Konflikt-Forschung ein Feld sein kann, was eigene Dachgesellschaften erzeugt, wir haben ein eigenes Haus-Journal. Weil wir gesagt haben, es passt eigentlich kein disziplinär verortetes Journal zu dem was wir machen. Es passt auch nicht in die Weltlage, das kommt dazu.
Also mein Vorgänger hat auch ein International Journal of Conflict and Violence ins Leben gerufen mit der faszinierenden Idee, wir haben Gewalt-Konflikt-Forschung in Regionen, wo Gewalt und Konflikt an der Tagesordnung ist und wo Forschung sehr schwierig ist. Wir brauchen ein Format, das sich nicht an den disziplinären und in den Exzellenzkriterien da orientiert, sondern erst mal an den Menschen die Forschung machen. Die sollen die Möglichkeit haben zu publizieren und wir helfen dabei, dieses Ganze nach den Standards zu erfüllen. Und das wäre transdisziplinär. Man denkt über die Credits nach. Und ich glaube das ist auch die Zukunft. Wir haben ja vollkommen neue jetzt auch durch die Einführung neuer Studiengänge, durch die internationale Zusammenarbeit sehen wir ja immer mehr, dass Forschungsfelder entstehen, die in den klassischen Disziplinen nicht einfach zu verorten sind.
Müssten die dann auch zwangsläufig internationale Äquivalente haben oder reicht das, wenn sich das zum Beispiel nur in Deutschland entwickelt?
Na das reicht, wenn wir hier starten. Also ich habe jetzt die Erfahrung gemacht, wir starten das ja, unsere Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung ist erst mal offen gedacht, das ist offene Wissenschaft. Und bei mir spielen nationale Grenzen überhaupt gar keine Rolle. Gar keine Rolle. Wir beschäftigen und gerade mit Rechtspopulismus und dieses nur mit einem deutschen Blick zu machen wäre vollkommen falsch. Weil gerade im Bereich der Gewalt- und Konfliktforschung sehen wir, dass internationale Phänomene erzeugen Gewalt hier vor Ort. Probleme, die wir in Deutschland haben, übersteigen nationale Grenzen. Ich bin sehr aktiv im Bereich der Integrations- und Migrationsforschung, das war mein Habilitationsthema. Psychologie der Akulturation, wie eignen Menschen neue kulturelle Umgebung an. Ich habe das damals auch transdisziplinär versucht zu entwickeln. Das war ein Problem bei der Verteidigung der Habilitation, weil man sich dann wieder auf die disziplinären Grenzen einlassen muss.
Aber dieses Phänomen, wie eignen Menschen neue kulturelle Umwelten an, wenn sie wandern, wenn sie die Wohnung wechseln. Wir denken immer an Migration, aber Akulturationsprozesse sind eigentlich etwas was alltäglich ist und was viele Menschen erleben. Wir leben in globalen Gesellschaften, leben in postmigrantischen, postnationalen – das wird gerade diskutiert – und wenn man die Gesellschaftsformen anguckt und wir machen Forschung in Gesellschaften, nicht so sehr zwischen, aber in Gesellschaften sehen wir Phänomene, die verlassen nationale Grenzen und das ist auch ganz gut so.
Da sehe ich jetzt so ein bisschen auch einen Bezug vielleicht zu Ihrem initialen Werdegang. Es ist richtig, dass Sie außer Psychologie auch noch evangelische Theorie studiert haben?
Nein Theologie. Evangelische Theorie wäre schön, das wäre auch mal ein neues Feld. Das wäre gar nicht so schlecht. Gibt es auch.
Okay, ein Versprecher kann …
Nein das gibt es ja auch, ist interessant.
Ach wirklich.
Ja ich wusste gar nicht was ich studieren wollte ehrlich. Also mir ging es genauso wie jungen Menschen heute, wenn Sie die mit 18/19 fragen, was willst du denn mal studieren? Das ist ja die Frage, was willst du werden. Wir werden beim Gehen. Das finde ich auch eine schöne Tradition. Ich habe erst mal auf den Zivildienst gewartet, der nicht funktioniert hat, weil ich nicht anerkannt wurde als Kriegsdienstverweigerer damals, weil ich immer wieder durch die Prüfungen gefallen bin auf abenteuerliche Art und Weise. Immer wieder dagegen geklagt habe, immer wieder gewonnen habe. Und dann irgendwann habe ich gesagt, so jetzt muss ich irgendetwas tun und studieren ist die größte Freiheit, das zu tun. Das wusste ich, das ist einfach superklasse Studium. Die einen gehen in die Arbeit und wir können studieren. Und dann habe ich Lehramt studiert, das fand ich ganz furchtbar. Ein Semester. Und wie das immer so ist im Leben, ich hatte einen Mentor, einen evangelischen Theologen, der sich mit Religionsvergleichen beschäftigt hat und der hat mir gesagt, du musst jetzt ganz schnell dieses Lehramtsstudium verlassen.
Geh in das Vollstudium und danach kannst du Religionsvergleich studieren, unterreligiöse Studien machen und so weiter, es ist gut aber ein Vollstudium zu haben. Das heißt die Sprachen zu lernen, die evangelische Theologie zu lernen und danach kann man das tun. Und so ist es dazu gekommen, ich habe mich da rein gesetzt in das Studium in Bochum. Habe dann aber gemerkt, mir fehlt nun etwas in diesem Studium. Mir fehlt nämlich empirisches Wissen zu diesem Theologiestudium. Und wie das dann so ist, man hat einen Kommilitonen, der sagt, ich studiere auch noch Psychologie. Alle haben das für wahnsinnig gehalten zwei Vollstudiengänge. Ich bin dann aber mitgegangen und war dann fasziniert. Fasziniert weil auf der einen Seite wir dieses sehr naturwissenschaftlich orientierte Fach der Psychologie haben. Wo man erst mal durch die Methoden muss, die Experimentalmethoden, die Beobachtungsmethoden bis hin dann in Bereiche der klinischen Psychologie hinein.
Wo wir versuchen zu verstehen, was wollen Menschen, was denken Menschen, was fühlen Menschen, warum tun sie es so? Und dann in dem Bereich der Theologie zu sitzen, wo wir uns mit Grundfragen von Gesellschaft, mit Ethik, Moral, Dogmatik und so weiter beschäftigen. Wo man ja auch lernt, dass beide Fächer hohe Überschneidungen haben. Also evangelische Theologie zum Beispiel verkündet ja keine Wahrheiten, sondern es geht da um die Frage, wo entsteht Religion, wie entsteht es. Und dann habe ich das beides gemacht und dann kam die Karriere aber in der Psychologie. Man macht seine Karriere durch Mentoren. Ich hatte einen Mentor, Professor Peter Schönbach, Professor Ulrich Wagner, die dann irgendwann mich als studentische Hilfskraft eingestellt haben. Sich wahrscheinlich über Strecken geärgert haben, weil ich immer diese beiden Studiengänge gemacht habe und irgendwann dann auch mein Hebraicum Machen musste und dann nicht so viel Zeit hatte. Die haben mir aber eine riesige Chance gegeben und das war einen großen Teil meiner Zeit als studentische Hilfskraft mit einem Büro.
Ich habe ein Büro geteilt, wir hatten ein Büro als studentische Hilfskräfte. Das heißt ich hatte einen Raum, in dem ich mich dann als Student entwickeln konnte und ich war früh in Experimentalforschung. Ulrich Wagner hat mich sehr früh schon als Student mit auf den Kongress genommen und ich musste einen Vortrag halten. Das war die absolute Hölle, aber das war wichtig, um da zu bestehen und zu lernen, vor diesen exzellenten Wissenschaftlern, die kritische Fragen stellen. Und ich war eben irgendwann tatsächlich der absolute Vollzeitstudent und konnte davon leben. Ich konnte davon leben, das heißt das Geld für die studentische Hilfskraftstelle hat gereicht, um das Studium zu finanzieren. Ich musste nicht mehr Taxifahren, ich bin nicht mehr arbeiten gegangen, sondern konnte in der Uni mein Geld verdienen. Ich werde das nie vergessen, das ist ein Traum, mit einem Büro. Und das ermöglicht eigentlich, diese Bedingungen ermöglichen das eigentlich. Ich halte mich selbst nicht für exzellent, sondern für durchschnittlich, aber ich habe Bedingungen gehabt, die waren überdurchschnittlich.
Bedingungen, die man heute wahrscheinlich nicht so ohne weiteres findet.
Die wir versuchen zu realisieren am Institut. Also so gut wie es geht. Also heute sind die Wissenschaftskarrieren insofern schwieriger, als ich gerade merke, dass über die Befristungsverhältnisse und so weiter in Deutschland meine Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter sehr unter einem Druck stehen. Das heißt diese Balance zwischen dem was ich als individuelle Lebensplanung versuchen und dem was universitäre Systeme vorgeben an Kriterien das in Balance zu kriegen wird nicht einfacher.
Was machen Sie da konkret, um Studenten recht zu machen?
Ich mache sehr konkret was ich jetzt sehr deutlich gemacht habe, ist im Grunde genommen das was ich erfahren habe. Das heißt relativ früh auf die Förderung einzugehen. Das heißt wenn bei uns im Institut studentische Hilfskräfte arbeiten und sie haben Interesse und Lust an Forschung. Ich musste einen Entwicklungsplan fürs Institut machen, dann habe ich gesagt, eigentlich die Projekte, in denen sie arbeiten, oder wir in der Verwaltung, wenn sie dort arbeiten, dann haben wir eine Leitlinie und die heißt fördern beim Forschen. Das heißt wir nehmen sie relativ früh mit in Projekte, wenn sie daran denn Interesse haben. Wenn niemand Interesse daran hat, wenn man sagt, ich bin studentische Hilfskraft, mir reicht kopieren, ich will mein Geld verdienen, ist das auch vollkommen okay. Aber die die Interesse daran haben nehmen wir in den Institutsalltag mit hinein, so dass wir dann eben die Karrieren besser und schneller planen können.
Das Problem ist ja bei uns auch, dass in der Gewalt-Konflikt-Forschung die Zeit, um Phänomene zu durchdringen, immer länger sein muss. Also wenn Sie sich gerade beschäftigen mit der Frage, warum sich in Deutschland ein junger Mensch so radikalisiert, dass er in den Dschihad ziehen will, um dieses zu verstehen und daraus dann eine Promotion zu basteln.
Muss man ein paar Jahre beobachten.
Muss man beobachten. Wir analysieren Vorurteile. Und wir analysieren das über eine lange Zeit. Das heißt ich brauche viele Messzeitpunkte, was normal ist, aber dann das mit einer Karriere zu verbinden. Wir müssen auch sehen, die Projektlaufzeiten bei uns am Institut bei vielen Projekten sind relativ kurz. Wir stückeln Verträge ein Jahr, zwei Jahre und so weiter. Das heißt wir basteln Karrieren über verschiedene Projekte. Und in den Projekten, die Projekte müssen gemacht werden. Das ist wirklich nicht ganz einfach. Das habe ich ja auch alles selber erfahren. Und insofern versuchen wir das so gut wie es geht zu machen, aber der Druck und die Zeitabstände sind schon relativ kurz geworden, um sich da noch geeignet zu qualifizieren.
In welchen Studiengängen sind denn die Studenten in Ihrem Institut?
Also bei uns, ich habe ja einen riesengroßen Vorteil, theoretisch kann ich promovieren in der Erziehungswissenschaft, weil da ist meine Stelle, haushalterisch angeordnet. Und da habe ich auch die Professur, eben für Konfliktforschung und Sozialisation. Aber ich bin kooptiert in der Soziologie, da kann ich promovieren, in der Psychologie da habe ich die weniger. Also das sind die drei Fächer, aber wir bemühen uns, das ist ja das Schöne an dem Institut, das Institut besteht auch aus anderen Professuren, dass wir eigentlich Zugänge zu allen Fakultäten haben. Das ist in Bielefeld auch tatsächlich immer angelegt gewesen. Also die Universität Bielefeld, die ja im zweitgrößten Gebäude Europas beheimatet ist, lohnt sich wirklich, da mal hinzufahren.
Zweitgrößte?
Ja, auch wenn Bielefeld ja wahrscheinlich nicht existiert wie Wikipedia sagt und wir in Bielefeld. Und das geht auch auf die Forscherinnen und Forscher zurück, wirklich emsig daran sind, diesen Bielefeldmythos aufrecht zu erhalten, ist die Idee in Bielefeld tatsächlich eine des Grenzenüberschreitens, das heißt das Interdisziplinäre, das wird dort sehr gefördert und wir haben relativ kurze Wege. Das ist schon als Standort relativ gut.
Und die Stadt hat ja gelernt, mit diesem Mythos wunderbar zu leben.
Naja sie hat endlich mal gelernt, dass man damit eben auch, das ist auch Image. Also die Stadt hadert immer mit ihrem Image. Interessanterweise als ich 2008 dorthin gekommen bin, für mich ist der Zusammenhang zwischen Forschung und Stadtgesellschaft immer wichtiger geworden. Also ich war gestern den ganzen Tag auf den Stadtentwicklungsgesprächen, die in Bielefeld stattfinden mit vielen Personen, die in dem Bereich Bauen vor allen Dingen tätig sind. Ich habe mit Architekten diskutiert, mit Stadtplanern und so weiter, warum interessieren die sich für unsere Konfliktforschung? Weil wir sehen, dass wir in Gesellschaften leben, wo jetzt im Moment zwar nationale Grenzen hochgezogen werden, aber auf der anderen Seite genau das Gegenmodell da ist, dass wir stärker kommunal und mehr transnational zugleich denken. Das erzählt uns die ganze Migration. Man muss kommunal, lokal sehr stark sein.
Es wird gekämpft um die Stadtgesellschaften und so weiter. Und dann merkt man, dass Städte und Universitäten viel voneinander lernen und gewinnen können und das ist in Bielefeld auch passiert. Ich habe einen wirklich herausragendes Projekt, auf das wir sehr stolz sind, wir als Institut zusammen mit dem Stadtsportbund und der Stadt vergeben in Bielfeld allen vierjährigen Kindern, allen Kindern, wir erreichen tatsächlich fast alle Kinder, bis auf einige Kinder aus fundamentalistisch evangelikalen Familien, die es einfach ablehnen. Wir erreichen fast alle Kinder. Wir geben ihnen eine gratis Mitgliedschaft für einen Sportverein. Wir begleiten das ganze Projekt wissenschaftlich. Wir evaluieren nicht nur, ob es einen Effekt hat, sondern wir steuern es wissenschaftlich, wenn es irgendwo hapert. Alle vierjährigen Kinder kriegen in Bielefeld eine Sportmitgliedschaft und das Siegel Universität Bielefeld steht dabei mit drauf. Das ist unsere Idee von moderner Stadtgesellschaft, die aus wissenschaftlicher Evidenz heraus entsteht.
Das ist wirklich faszinierend, weil es funktioniert. Und wenn es irgendwo hakt, das heißt wir vergeben den Gutschein, dann geht ein wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter hin, das Kind kommt irgendwie nicht in dem Verein an, der wird nicht eingelöst, wir gründen Vereine und so weiter.
Ach da werden noch extra Vereine dafür gegründet?
Naja wir haben Stadtteile, das sind die prekären Stadtteile, in denen sind die Vereine klamm oder die Vereine existieren nicht, dann vergeben wir diesen Gutschein und dann müssen wir auch für ein Angebot sorgen. Und dann ist es überhaupt gar kein Problem mal eben eine Sportgruppe. Es geht um vierjährige Kinder, die machen keinen Spitzensport. Das sollen die auch gar nicht machen. Sondern die sollen Integration in Stadtgesellschaft hinein lernen, bevor sie in der Stadtgesellschaft lernen, dass auch Städte nach bestimmten sozialen Klassen und so weiter geordnet sind. Das entsteht dann so aus Forschungsevidenz, wenn Kategorisierungsprozesse, dass wir lernen relativ früh, andere Menschen kann man kategorisieren in soziale Gruppen, ihnen Merkmale zuordnen und dann setzt Diskriminierung ein, wenn wir merken, dass es so früh noch gar nicht angelegt ist, dann holen wir die Kinder da in die Stadtgesellschaft und versuchen sie so natürlich nicht einfach nur an den Sportverein zu bringen. 70% verbleiben, auch wenn sie danach zahlen müssen, das ist ein faszinierender Wert.
Sondern wir begleiten, was lernen Kinder? Stimmt die These, die wissenschaftliche These, das Sport konfliktfähig macht. Das ist ja eine interessante Annahme. Wir können aber mit dem Projekt auch Begleitforschung machen und das untersuchen. Dann stehen wir und sagen, aber für Vierjährige gibt es jetzt irgendwie keine Messinstrumente für Konfliktfähigkeit, was soll das denn sein? Was sind die Indikatoren? Weniger Streit, weniger laut reden und so weiter. Dann entwickeln wir die mit Bachelor- und Masterarbeitet und Promotionen und so weiter. Das ist nur ein Beispiel für Science to Action, so heißt das.
Ja und jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip auch schon mitten im Thema, die schon mehrfach erwähnte Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung, das steht jetzt ganz klar im Mittelpunkt des Instituts natürlich und auch Ihrer konkreten Arbeit. Gut das war jetzt schon ein erster Einblick, man fängt halt schon sehr früh an. Bzw. Ich vermute mal, dieses Projekt ist einfach auch aus diesen Erkenntnissen heraus entstanden, man muss halt „get them while they are young“, also wenn man eben früh anfängt zu steuern oder auch eben nur zu beobachten, dann kann man einerseits Erkenntnisse gewinnen dabei, aber vielleicht auch schon Ergebnisse erzielen. Das ist ja im Prinzip gleichzeitig eine pädagogische Maßnahme als auch eine wissenschaftliche Forschung in einem.
Genau. Das sind moderne Projektformate. Da mischt sich Evaluation und Begleitforschung, Grundlagenforschung und so weiter. Das ist ein Projekt, wo ich nur zeigen kann, das entsteht wieder aus einer Erkenntnis eben, aus der Erkenntnis, dass Forschung und Stadtgesellschaft Bedeutung bekommt, dass wir das versuchen miteinander zu koppeln und daraus dann Projekte entwickeln. Im Kern geht es natürlich bei uns im Institut auch weitenteils um Grundlagenforschung. Wir haben eine Mixfinanzierung von Projekten. Wir haben zum Teil Projekte aus öffentlichen Ausschreibungen, wenn es darum geht zu evaluieren, welche Deradikalisierungsprojekte bei Gewalt funktionieren, das sind befristete Projekte, auf die wir reagieren. Wir versuchen immer stärker und immer mehr natürlich Projekte einzuwerben über die klassische Grundlagenforschung, weil es mehr Sicherheit auch für die Nachwuchskarrieren bietet und größere Freiräume.
Es ist ja ein riesengroßer Freiraum der Forschung, der Teil der Forschung, die wir machen. Im Bereich Konflikt und Gewalt gibt es vieles, aber die Grundlagenforschung genießt Freiräume, die andere nicht haben und deswegen versuchen wir solche Projekte einzuwerben. Da geht es um klassische Forschungsformate, DFG vor allen Dingen an erste Stelle, VW-Stiftung und so weiter. Darüber Projekte in der Grundlagenforschung. Ursachen, Ausdrucksformen, Folgen von Konflikten. Konflikt und Gewalt, wann führen Konflikte, die ja per se erst mal nicht negativ sind, Gesellschaften entwickeln sich über Konflikte, wann führen sie aber zu Gewalt, wann kommt es zu extremer Gewalt? Wir haben jetzt lange in einem Forschungsverbund zu hochexpressiver Gewalt im öffentlichen Raum geforscht und das ist ein Teil, Radikalisierung Konflikt Gewalt, ein zweiter großer Teil ist bei uns, klassisch war es immer die Rechtsextremismus-Forschung, die jetzt immer stärker eine Extremismus-Forschung wird, weil wir neue Phänomene des Extremismus haben.
Islamismus und so weiter und dann ist eine sehr wesentliche Säule der ganze Bereich, den ich bezeichnen würde als Vorurteils- und Diskriminierungsforschung, jetzt mal mit Blick auf die Psychologie und Soziologie, den wir aber bezeichnen als Forschung über das Phänomen der gruppenbezogenen Menschenfeindlichkeit. Das heißt der Abwertung von anderen zur Herstellung von Ungleichheit gesellschaftlicher Gruppen. Das ist ein großer Teil, da führen wir jetzt seit 14 Jahren fast jährlich jetzt im Zweijahresrhythmus repräsentative Meinungsumfragen in Deutschland durch. Die sind öffentlich auch sehr bekannt, weil in diesem Forschungsformat haben wir immer gesagt, dass wir mit der Forschung auch die Erkenntnisse der Gesellschaft für Diskussion und Debatten bereitstellen.
Ja und das scheint ja aktueller denn je zu sein, diese Debatten zu führen. Man hat aber eher das Gefühl, dass es bisher eigentlich nur sehr eingeschränkt stattgefunden hat bzw. wenn es stattgefunden hat, dann doch immer stark von eigenen Vorurteilen in gewisser Hinsicht geprägt. Es gab da immer klare Vorstellungen davon, wer sozusagen der eigentliche Auslöser der Probleme ist. Beispiel Fußballfans, wo sich Gewalt in den Stadien entlädt, dass natürlich dann von der Öffentlichkeit den Fans, dem Fußball, den Vereinen, dem Umfeld, dem Sport vielleicht an sich zugeschrieben wird. Vereine aber dann auf der anderen Seite sagen, wir baden noch nur die Versäumnisse der Gesellschaft hier aus. Das sind halt schwierig zu führende Debatten. Ist das auch ein Thema, was bei Ihnen wichtig ist?
Das ist sehr schwierig zu führen. Ja das ist gut, dass Sie es ansprechen. Ich hätte es beinahe vergessen. Wir haben eine Fachstelle Fußball und Konflikt ausgegründet, weil wir ein sehr großes Forschungsprojekt hatten zusammen mit anderen Universitäten, Potsdam und Kassel, welches ein unheimliches Forschungsprojekt ist. Es wurde finanziert von Deutschem Fußballbund und Deutscher Fußballliga. Fußballbund ist ja der Verein, die Deutsche Fußballliga ist verantwortlich für die 1. und 2. Liga. Ich war dort sehr lange wissenschaftlicher Beirat der Deutschen Fußballliga, um mit einem kleinen Kreis von Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftlern zu diskutieren, wie kann man Stadionsicherheit erhöhen, wie kann vor allen Dingen Fans so unterstützen, dass sie Konflikte gewaltfrei regulieren können. Wie kann man zu besseren Debatten unter den Akteuren, die im Fußball tätig sind, führen. Das haben wir gemacht. Und dann haben wir gesagt, wir brauchen dringend Evidenz, wir brauchen Daten.
Wir brauchen Daten dazu, wie nehmen überhaupt Fans im Stadion solche Konflikte und Gewalt wahr, wann kommt es zu dieser Stadiongewalt? Weil wir gemerkt haben, dass wir oft unvermittelbare und unvereinbare Interessenskonflikte im Fußball hatten. Die sind hochspannend und das heißt, das haben Sie angesprochen, wir haben einen Fall von Gewalt, es passiert etwas, was weiß ich, klassischer Fall Pyro wird gezündet, das ist ja hochgradig verboten, auch untersucht, dass es hochgradig gefährlich ist, trotzdem machen Fans das in der Kurve. Und aus diesem Pyrozünden, wir werden das jetzt bei der Europameisterschaft jetzt sehen, entstehen wahnsinnig starke Konflikte, große Konflikte, wie geht man damit um? Und jetzt sind die Akteure im Feld, in diesem Konfliktfeld, jetzt sagen die Polizeien, wir müssen die Polizeien aufrüsten und besser ausrüsten. Jetzt sagen die Fans, genau das ist ein Angriff auf das was wir mühselig erarbeitet haben, gegen die Kommerzialisierung des Fußballs, die Autonomie wird eingeschränkt.
Jetzt die Vereine, das ist uns eigentlich alles egal, macht das Problem mal irgendwie weg. Und dann gibt es die Sicherheitsbeauftragten und und und. Und in diesem Konfliktfeld haben wir gesagt, hilft eigentlich als Brücke nur Forschung, genau hinsehen, genau angucken, was sind die Ursachen und was für Formen von Konfliktgewalt haben wir denn? Wir müssen dort sehen, es gibt mediale Überinterpretation, weil Medien sind ja auch darauf angewiesen, dass sie jetzt bestimmte Konfliktlagen inszenieren können. Und Fußball ist, viele Konflikte entstehen durch diese medialen Inszenierungen oder durch diese Empörungskultur, die es sehr stark gibt auch in den Vereinen, auch in Bereichen der Sicherheit, weil man einfach die eigenen Interessen in den Vordergrund stellt und solche Konflikte nutzt, um eigene Interessen durchzusetzen. Also wenn ich jetzt in der Gewerkschaft der Polizei wäre, würde ich nach jedem Vorfall auch sagen, wir müssen die Polizei verstärken.
Aber die Fans sagen genau das Gegenteil, die sagen, wenn ihr jetzt mal Sicherheit runter fahren würdet – und in dem Feld haben wir geforscht und dann gibt es interessante Beobachtungen, großer Teil der Konflikte und Gewalt sind Inszenierungen. Das heißt sie dienen eigentlich von Machtdemonstrationen, manche sind auch dazu da …
Auf beiden Seiten?
Jaja, dann gibt es Einsätze und dann reden wir mit Fans und Polizeien und versuchen als Wissenschaft eine Brücke zu machen. Wir gucken uns zum Beispiel Einsätze und auch Bewegungen in Fangruppen in Kurven an, stellen fest, insbesondere entsteht Gewalt dann, wenn Polizeien auf einem bestimmten Weg ins Stadion gehen. Das heißt wenn sie von oben mit einer Hundertschaft in eine Kurve hineingehen ist die Konfliktgefahr und die Gewaltgefahr viel höher als wenn man von unten geht sichtbar. Und das sind solche Dinge, da können wir mit Forschung etwas transparent machen für alle und dann können die Partner das verhandeln. Also das machen wir nicht im Auftrag, um jetzt allein Stadionsicherheit zu verbessern und so weiter, sondern da sieht man, wir nehmen die Thesen der einzelnen Akteure ernst und als Wissenschaft können wir diese Thesen empirisch gegeneinander spielen und das ist das eigentlich hochinteressante und das ist dann natürlich auch die Zukunft der Wissens- und Wissenschaftsgesellschaft und deswegen machen wir Wissenschaft.
Weil wir glaube nicht an einfache Wahrheiten, sondern gerade im Geistes- und Sozialwissenschaften können wir über die empirische Prüfung von unterschiedlichen Annahmen tatsächlich dazu führen, dass sich etwas bewegt. Und da hat man viel getan im Fußball.
Ich will nicht nur über Fußball reden.
Nein, das ist ein großes Projekt.
Ja aber es ist vielleicht ein ganz guter Startpunkt, mir fällt in dem Zusammenhang auch noch ein, in den 90er Jahren ging das ja los mit diesem Phänomen der Hooligans, die ja sozusagen zwar im Fußballumfeld stattfand, natürlich dann auch genauso erst mal der Fußballszene auch so per se zugeschrieben wurde, aber sich ja eigentlich relativ schnell als so eine reine Gewaltszene oder so eine dedizierte Gewaltszene auch definiert hat. Die Gesellschaft stand da auch fassungslos ein wenig davor, weil man sich das überhaupt gar nicht klar machen kann, so Spaß an Gewalt zu haben oder zumindest so exzessiv auszuleben, sogar mit dieser Bereitschaft loszuziehen, um genau das dann auch auszuleben. Haben Sie sich das sicherlich auch mal näher angeschaut. Was sind denn so die Erkenntnisse über diese Szene und haben wir die in der Form eigentlich noch?
Naja wir haben sie und haben sie nicht. Weil jetzt, das wissen ja die meisten Hörerinnen und Hörer wahrscheinlich, dass es ja diesen großen Hooligan-Aufmarsch in Köln gab. Am Kölner Bahnhof, wo 5000 Hooligans unter diesem Label HoGeSa – Hooligans gegen Salafisten sehr öffentlich im Raum waren, dort auch Krawall gemacht haben. Dort auch einen Polizeieinsatzwagen, das war das was passierte, neben so Beleidigungen auf dem Weg und am Bahnhof und martialisches Auftreten, aber vor allen Dingen hat es dazu geführt, dass ein Polizeieinsatzwagen gekippt worden ist, es war ein Bielefelder Wagen. Ich analysiere noch, ob das ein Zeichen war, weil in Bielefeld die Polizei mit Fans von Dynamo Dresden aus ihrer Sicht sehr ruppig umgegangen ist beim Spiel in Bielefeld. Also mit einem Wasserwerfer. Das ist immer so etwas zum Beispiel was normativ ausgehandelt wird.
Wenn der Wasserwerfer erscheint sagen die Fans ist das ein deutliches Zeichen, dass es jetzt eben eine Eskalationsstufe höher geht. Da sind die Hooligans jetzt unter HoGeSa aufgetaucht. Die gibt es zum Teil auch noch. Es gab noch andere Veranstaltungen. Die sind auch jetzt, da gibt es dann eben kulturelle Bewegung, diese HoGeSa-Bewegung, sehr weit an den rechtsextremen Rand gegangen. Hat tatsächlich auch mit anderen sozialen Bewegungen, Pegida und so weiter, Kontakt aufgenommen, das ist hochspannend und hat sich dann aber irgendwann mal gesagt, nein dieser ganze Bereich des ideologischen, der bei Pegida gebaut wird, das heißt es geht um nationale Identität, es geht um politische Interessen, ist nicht vereinbar mit unserer Hooligan-Identität. Hat sich dann wieder distanziert, ist in kleinen Splittergruppen noch da, aber daran merkt man, dass so ein Phänomen der Hooligans, die eigentlich im öffentlichen Raum immer sehr bestimmend auftreten, das ist unsere Identität.
Und über das Zeigen von Gewalt oder Gewaltverabredung, das waren ja die 80er Jahre. Die 80er Jahre, vor allen Dingen subkulturelle, jugendkulturelle Gruppen, Hooligans Identifikation und man verabredet sich in einem bestimmten Raum und jenseits aller Beobachtung von Sicherheitsbehörden, auch Forscherinnen und Forscher, zum gemeinsamen Kampf. Das hat sich verschoben, dadurch dass sich die Gesellschaft verändert hat. Und HoGeSa ist praktisch ein Versuch einer Reunion von Althooligans, um diese alte Hooligan-Identität und Tradition noch einmal zu bestärken. Aber vollkommen neu, denn jetzt mussten sie sich HoGeSa nennen, also gegen die Salafisten, die waren vorher als Scharia-Polizei aufgetreten und die Hooligans selber in ihrer Gewalt haben – und das ist super interessant für Konfliktforschung – haben eigentlich etwas kopiert, was die Salafisten gemacht haben oder die Neosalafisten, die gewaltbereiten, nämlich sich anzulegen massiv mit der Polizei.
Also die Polizei ist immer Konfliktgegner von beiden, den Konflikt sucht man und das hat man nun auch gesucht. Und da sieht man diese ganzen Verwirbelungen, das heißt man kann diese subkulturelle reine Hooligan-Identität nicht mehr halten und dann verändert sich das. Das ist hochgradig spannend.
Aber was treibt denn den einzelnen in so eine Bewegung?
Ja, also wir haben ja eine ganze Reihe von neueren gewaltorientierten Gruppen. Beim Hooliganism ist es vor allen Dingen immer noch zum Teil klassisch subkulturell. Zum teil treibt es Jugendliche, die fasziniert sind von dieser massiven starken Identitätspräsentation, dass sie dort eine Clique haben, die ihre sozialen Motive in einem erhöhten Ausmaß befriedigen kann, wo das an anderen Stellen überhaupt nicht mehr möglich ist. Da gibt es ja schon in den 90er Jahren dann Studien, die zum Beispiel zeigen, dass da die Gewalt eine Erlebniswelt bietet. Die Gewalt, das Ausüben, das Auftreten, das Inszenieren von Gewalt, das ist genau das Erlebnis, der Kick, der Identität erzeugen kann. Das ist das attraktive beim Hooliganism. Gewalt ist eben nicht nur um einen Feind zu zerstören oder einen Feind zu vernichten auf der kommunikativen Ebene, sondern Gewalt bietet immer auch eine Erlebniswelt. Das wissen wir in unserer Gesellschaft.
Also ist sozusagen auch Kompensation für eine Langeweile?
Nein es ist nicht unbedingt Kompensation, sondern es ist ein Teil dessen was mich ausmachen kann. Ich kompensiere nichts. Die alte Hypothese, dass wir frustrierte Jugendliche haben, die dann in diese Gruppen hineingehen, dann Gewalt inszenieren und damit etwas kompensieren stimmt überhaupt nicht. Das ist eines der ganz großen gesellschaftlichen Irrtümer. Ich glaube man muss ein Leben darauf verbringen, um diesen Irrtum mal auszuräumen. Es ist auch nicht so, dass aus Frustration Menschlichkeit, Vorurteile, Abwertung … die alte Sündenbock-Theorie stimmt ja schon lange nicht mehr. In der Psychologie wissen wir das schon seit langem, da kommen andere Faktoren zu, aber das ist nicht mehr so wie bei Sigmund Freud das angemacht war. Oder bei Lorentz Dampfkesselmodell. Es gibt ein Ausmaß an Frustration und dann entlädt sich das oder man schickt eben den Sündenbock in die Wüste, der dann die ganzen Leiden und so weiter auf sich nimmt.
Sondern es ist nur Lifestyle?
Nein, das ist zum Teil – jetzt müssen wir gucken, es ist ja nicht so einfach – es ist für die einen tatsächlich ein Lifestyle. Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel die Gruppen der Ultras in den Stadien, das ist eine neue Gruppe, die entstanden ist, die überhaupt nicht zu verwechseln ist mit Hooligans und auch nicht gleichzusetzen ist mit Gewalt. Sondern Ultras haben eben eine Ultraidentifikation nicht mit dem Verein, sondern mit dem was sie als Verein definieren. Also nicht den kommerziellen, nicht den organisierten Fußball. Eigene Fanscenes, Zeitungen, eigene Kulturen, eigene Traditionen, Rituale, die sie in Autonomie ausführen wollen, ohne den Druck und die Kontrolle von außen. Und in diesen Gruppen sieht man in den empirischen Studien sind alle Bevölkerungsschichten. Und da treibt die einen eben dort das äußern ultimativer starker Identitäten, ich kann dort Dinge tun, die ich vielleicht in meinem Alltagsleben nicht tun kann.
Für wieder andere ist es dann eben eine Möglichkeit, auch aus prekären Verhältnissen heraus dort einen gleichen Status zu erhalten. Das ist ja etwas, was mich im Moment umtreibt in ganz anderen Bereichen. Wir beschäftigen uns gerade mit dschihadistischen Gruppen. Warum konvertiert jemand zum Beispiel und geht dann in eine hoch gewaltbereite Gruppe, die zum Teil dann sehr terrornah ideologisch orientiert ist und vielleicht dort sich radikalisiert? Und was wir zum Beispiel feststellen ist, dass diese Gruppen in Gesellschaften, die hochgradig kontrolliert und geschichtet sind, Heterogenität ertragen und akzeptieren in einem Ausmaß, wie wir das nicht akzeptieren. Das heißt eigentlich ist es interessant, viele Menschen wissen, dass bestimmte Gruppen wie Hooligans, dass bestimmte Gruppen wie ideologisch extreme Gruppen gesellschaftlich stigmatisiert sind, das macht es aber für manche Menschen hochgradig interessant, genau dort hinzugehen.
Weil sie selbst Stigmatisierung erleben und dort in diesen Gruppen genau nicht stigmatisiert werden, sondern als gleiche behandelt werden. Und das ist ein Moment, der ist interessant. Und wenn Sie fragen, was treibt die einzelnen Menschen, wir müssen ja immer sehr fein unterscheiden. Es gibt persönliche Faktoren, so personale Faktoren, bestimmte Disposition. Es gibt auch im Bereich schwerer Gewalt Psychopathologien, Soziopathien, die eine Rolle spielen. Die große Diskussion über Anders Breivik. Warum tötet ein Mensch so viele Menschen mit einer ideologischen Botschaft? Da guckt man natürlich erst mal in die Person hinein, in die Disposition. Das machen wir auch in Forschungsprojekten, in interdisziplinären Forschungsprojekten, dass wir mit Forensikern zusammenarbeiten, wenn es um schwere Gewalt geht. Dann gibt es aber die Ebene der interpersonalen Beziehung. Da fragt man da, gibt es denn soziale Konstellationen, aus denen Täterinnen und Täter kommen, die verantwortlich sind?
Wir haben zum Teil jungen Menschen, die haben schwere Beziehungen erlebt. Die sind nicht beziehungsfähig geworden und die finden dort ein Auffangbecken in den Gruppen. Ich bin ja ein gelernter Sozialpsychologe und wir haben uns sehr lange beschäftigt mit dem Konzept von sozialen Identitäten, das heißt wir haben in gewaltorientierten, konfliktorientierten Gruppen einen Switch von einer Persönlichkeit hin zu einem Gewinn sozialer Identität. Also Ultra sein, Ultra kann ich sein, ohne dass ich in irgendeiner Weise zurückfalle auf meine üblichen Beziehungen, meine Disposition, ich switche, ich verändere komplett meine Identität. Also ich habe schon im Theologiestudium einen guten Freund gehabt, mit dem ich zusammen studiert habe, der war Ultra bei rot-weiß-Essen, der ging jeden zweiten Samstag ins Stadion und hat sich dort geschlagen. Und am Montag saß der da und hat Ethik und Dogmatik studiert in der evangelischen Theologie. Der ist heute Pfarrer.
Der gesagt hat, es hat nichts zu tun mit dem was ich sonst mache. Da bin ich im Stadion nur der, und das ist dann kollektive Identität. Und dann gibt es aber auch die strukturellen Bedingungen, die mich dazu bringen. Also wir haben im Bereich der Radikalisierung junge Menschen, die werden dort hineingezogen. So etwas habe ich ja nicht selbst in der Hand. Das heißt sie werden abgeholt von anderen Gruppen, das ist etwas was im Moment stattfindet. Wir haben große Fluchtbewegung in Deutschland, das ist immer extrem attraktiv, auch für extremistische Gruppen. Die gehen dorthin und holen Menschen ab und sagen, wir geben dir das was du brauchst. Ich habe mich in der Forschung sehr stark orientiert bei der Frage, weil ich eben psychologisches Interesse habe, man wird das ja nicht los. Also man ist ja so geprägt und ich merke, dass ich immer wieder auf Individuen und Gruppen gucke und erst dann auf die Strukturen, aber wir haben in unseren Analysen, zur Frage warum werten Menschen andere Menschen ab, nur weil sie einer andern Gruppe angehören?
Antisemitismus, Islamfeindlichkeit und so weiter und was ist der persönliche Anteil daran, was treibt uns dahin? Ich denke zunehmend, es ist die Erfüllung von fünf zentralen sozialen Motiven. Mit der Gewalt kann ich fünf Motive erfüllen, die jetzt unterschiedlich ausgeprägt sein können, und die unterschiedlich dominant sein können. 1. Ich kann Zugehörigkeit gewinnen. Wir alle brauchen und suchen Zugehörigkeit. Wir wollen wissen, wer wir sind und dazu brauchen wir die anderen und Zugehörigkeiten und Identitäten spielen eine große Rolle. Das zweite Motiv ist, wir wollen die Welt verstehen. Also im Moment leben wir ja in Zeiten, wo ich zum Beispiel zu dem Thema Konflikt und Gewalt kaum noch Zeit zum Atmen haben, weil wir so viele Anfragen kriegen. Können Sie hier etwas sagen, können Sie uns das erklären, können Sie zu einem Vortrag kommen? Das liegt ja vor allen daran, dass die Menschen das Motiv haben, zu verstehen, was passiert hier eigentlich gerade? Rücken wir nach rechts, schaffen wir das mit den Flüchtlingen?
Also die Menschen sehen Konflikt, die sehen auch Gewalt. Wir leben in einer extrem gewaltorientierten Zeit, gemessen an menschenfeindlichen Straftaten. Das hat ein Ausmaß, das wir in den 90er Jahren nicht hatten und damals war es schon im Bereich der Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung schon der Teufel los. Aber heute hat es noch ein höheres Ausmaß. Heute werden viele Menschen reingezogen in diese Gewalttaten und radikalisieren sich, die es vorher nicht waren. Spaltungen nehmen zu und so weiter.
Aber die Gruppen suchen auch nach Weltverständnis dadurch?
Ja ja. Also tatsächlich, ich meine das ist ja eine alte Erkenntnis.
Also man hat nicht immer den Eindruck, dass Weltverständnis jetzt vorherrschend wäre.
Nein es geht nicht um Weltverständnis in unseren humanistischen Denktraditionen, sondern es geht darum, Erklärungen zu haben. Woran liegt es, dass wir jetzt am Wohlstand nicht so teilhaben, obwohl wir hören im Moment, wir leben ja in einem Land, wo wir im Moment eigentlich uns entspannen können. Wir leben in Deutschland in einem Land in Europa, wir müssten eigentlich das entspannteste Volk der Erde sein oder zumindest in Europa. Allen anderen Ländern geht es schlechter nur uns nicht. Gucken wir Arbeitslosenquote an, gucken wir an, ob die Zuwanderung von Geflüchteten, die immer da kursiert die Zahl von einer Million, das ist ja gar nicht so, aber das ist eine massiv hohe Zahl, nicht zu dramatischen ökonomischen Effekten geführt hat. Die wir alle erwartet haben, die populistisch herbeigeredet werden und und und. Ich könnte jetzt viele Indikatoren aufzählen, warum es eigentlich zu solchen sogenannten sozialen Verwerfungen, also der massiven Gewalt, gar nicht führen müsste.
Aber wir merken, dass Populismus extrem attraktiv geworden ist. Woran liegt das? Viele Menschen haben überhaupt gar keine Kontakte. Haben überhaupt gar keine Erfahrung. Haben aber massiv Fragen, was zum Beispiel in Bezug auf Flucht los ist. Wer kommt da? Wo kommen die hin? Ist das ein Problem, ist das kein Problem? Ich meine, die Medien sind ja voll davon. Die stellen diese Fragen, geben dann auch Antworten, aber sie regen ja dazu an, darüber nachzudenken. Das tun die Menschen. Und wir leben in einer komplett neuen Gesellschaft. Wir können uns massiv viel schneller informieren und wir können medial massiv viel schneller teilhaben. Ich weiß es gibt große Diskussionen zu Teilhabe und Partizipation und demokratischen Strukturen, aber medial können wir teilhaben. Ich kann eine Nachricht lesen und kann eine Nachricht sofort weiter twittern und bin selbst ein Medienproduzent und das geht einher mit einem Interesse, ich möchte das verstehen.
Ich bin ja in vielen Kommunen. Also wir haben jetzt zwei Jahre erlebt, dass Kommunen sich damit beschäftigen, wer kommt heute Nacht und so weiter? Das interessiert die Leute schon. Thema Sicherheit, das interessiert die Leute schon. Lebt man sicher oder unsicher? Wir haben Terroranschläge. Ist doch vollkommen normal, dass wir viele Phänomene und Probleme in der Gesellschaft haben, die Verunsicherung erzeugen. Und das wissen wir nun aus der Theorie sozialer Vergleichsprozesse von Leon Festinger, wenn wir unsicher sind, - was passiert durch Flucht, was passiert durch Terror oder ist es draußen warm oder kalt – wenn wir verunsichert sind, dann fragen wir unsere Umgebung und dabei fragen wir andere, von denen wir vermuten, sie sind wahrscheinlich ähnlicher Meinung. Die sozialen Vergleichsprozesse erhöhen sich. Und die sind zurückzuführen auf die Frage Weltverständnis. Dann wollen wir aber, jetzt bin ich beim dritten Motiv, auch Kontrolle und Einfluss ausüben. Wir haben eine Meinung. Sie haben eine Meinung, ich habe eine Meinung zu den Phänomenen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir zufrieden sind nur damit, eine Meinung zu haben, sondern das geht einher mit einem Motiv, ich möchte mit dieser Meinung Wirkung erzeugen und ich möchte bitte auch verstanden werden.
Gehört werden.
Ich möchte gehört werden. Und das ist natürlich, Voice haben, Stimme haben. Ich habe studiert bei einem amerikanischen Motivationspsychologen Eric Klinger, der hat sich beschäftigt mit Weaning and Void, da geht es um Fragen, wann werden wir depressiv, im Zustand von Void, wenn wir keine Stimme mehr haben, wenn die Stimme weg ist und wir nicht gehört werden. Und er hat dieses Konzept von Meaning. Ich habe mich mit politischer Einstellungsbildung und -änderung beschäftigt, das ist schon sehr wichtig, Voice zu haben, Stimme zu haben. Das geben mir radikalisierte Gruppen, die geben mir eine Stimme. Und dann haben wir noch das Motiv Selbstwert. Wir wollen positiv wertgeschätzt werden, wir wollen Anerkennung haben. Dazu hat das Institut sehr lange gearbeitet zum Thema Anerkennung. Wir haben sehr viele Menschen, die haben je nach eigenem Anspruchsniveau empfinden die viel oder wenig Anerkennung. Und dann haben wir ein fünftes zentrales Motiv, sagt Susan Fiske, eine amerikanische Sozialpsychologin, wir wollen wissen, wem wir vertrauen können und wem gegenüber wir Misstrauen üben.
Und wenn man das mal zusammenzählt, dann spielen die schon eine extrem große Rolle diese Motive. Und wir führen jetzt sehr viele Analysen durch mit hoch radikalisierten jungen Heranwachsenden, die bereit sind zum Töten und man sieht, dass das vieles, - weil Sie gefragt haben, was treibt uns da rein – sehr unterschiedlich geprägt ist, genau von diesen Motiven. Die einen suchen die Zughörigkeit und genau die finden sie da. Die anderen suchen den Selbstwert, wieder andere suchen einfach Kontrolle und Dominanz, Machtorientierung. Da haben wir die ganze hegemoniale Männlichkeitsvorstellung, Macht ausüben und so weiter. Und das bieten mir radikalere, engere, kleinere Gruppen sehr viel schneller mit der hohen Gefahr, dass ich nicht übersehe dabei, dass ich in Gruppen bin, die außerhalb von üblichen Normen stehen.
Wie viele von diesen fünf Pfeilern müssen denn wegbrechen, um jemand auch zum Ausstieg aus so einer Bewegung zu bewegen?
Es reicht eigentlich, das ist eine unheimlich interessante Frage … Wir wissen noch nicht genau den goldenen Weg der Deradikalisierung oder der Abwendung, Distanzierung. Man nennt das heute Distanzierung, weil Radikalität an sich ist ja erst mal normativ nichts schlimmes. Manchmal muss man eben auch radikale Theorien definieren. Radikalität beschreibt es nicht, sondern Distanzierung, da geht es um soziale Phänomene. Die große Kunst besteht darin herauszufiltern, was ist genau das derzeit dominante Motiv. Wenn wir nur auf den Selbstwert gucken, das war eine Zeit lang so, naja die Gruppen bieten Selbstwert und jetzt bauen wir eine alternative Ausstiegsarbeit, die den erst mal Selbstwert und Anerkennung von außen verschafft. Übersehen wir vielleicht, dass wir Personen dabei haben, die wollen Dominanz und Kontrolle, die haben einen inflated self-esteem. Die haben ziemlich starken Selbstwert.
Neue amerikanische Forschung zeigt, dass Personen mit einem aufgeblasenen Selbstwert, ich ziehe in den Dschihad, das ist ja ein aufgeblasenes Selbstkonzept, die muss man anders abholen als solche, die eben nur Anerkennung suchen. Wenn das dominante Motiv Zugehörigkeit ist, ich suche eigentlich eine Antwort darauf wer ich bin und dieses in einer sozialen Gruppe, brauchen wir eigentlich eine ganz andere Ausstiegsarbeit, nämlich soziale Gruppen.
Das heißt, wenn man den Einzelnen oder die Einzelne betrachtet, dann hängt sehr viel von der Analyse ab, welche dieser fünf Motive spielen einfach eine große Rolle?
Ja.
Aber man könnte vielleicht sagen, also ist jetzt so eine Vermutung von mir, dass jetzt in so einer Bewegung vielen auch einfach an der Anerkennung liegt, die sie vielleicht an anderer Stelle nicht liegen und dass man damit schon relativ viel erreichen würde, wenn man denen klar macht, hör mal, die Anerkennung, die du hier erfährst, die besteht im Wesentlichen einfach nur an deiner Bereitschaft bedingungslos hier zu folgen und wenn du das mal rausrechnest bleibt nicht viel übrig.
Ja und dann kommt das Problem, daran verzweifeln gerade die ganze Arbeit mit Anders Breivik im Gefängnis, der praktisch die Anerkennungstheorie den Leuten, die mit ihm noch Kontakt haben, vorhält. Was im übrigen rechtsextreme Straftäter in Gefängnissen auch tun, sagen, ja ja ich weiß, mir fehlt Anerkennung, ich brauche mehr Anerkennung. Die spielen das. Weil die lesen ja mittlerweile auch Forschung und Forschungsergebnisse und spielen dann damit. Nein das Problem ist, wir machen Grundlagenforschung zu Radikalisierungsprozessen, aber sind jetzt eng in Zusammenarbeit und Kontakt mit einem Distanzierungsprojekt Wegweiser in Düsseldorf NRW, sehr erfolgreich in der Deradikalisierungsarbeit. Wir arbeiten zusammen mit Islamwissenschaftler Michael Kiefer. Das ist eine hoch spannende Arbeit, die den richtigen Weg da gehen.
Und das kann man durch Forschungsergebnisse begründen, wo sie sagen, eigentlich brauchen wir, bevor wir jetzt auf die einzelnen Motive und eine Kompensation eingehen, brauchen wir ein soziales Umfeld, in das hinein Menschen können, die sich dann distanzieren. Das heißt ja wir können versuchen auf einer rationalen Ebene den Menschen klarzumachen, in was für einer Bewegung sie sind.
Aber muss ihnen auch eine Alternative bieten?
Und dann bieten wir eine Alternative an. Das reicht aber nicht, ein alternatives Modell das reicht nicht. Bei hoch Gewaltorientierten muss man eh komplett andere Strategien fahren mit Identitätswechsel und so weiter. Das ganz wesentliche aber ist, dass wir gesehen haben, wenn wir mit Menschen zusammenarbeiten, die sich distanzieren, dann brauchen die vor allen Dingen ein extrem gutes soziales Netz, denn Radikalisierung entsteht nicht aus den Personen heraus, sondern auch aus einer bestimmten sozialen Umwelt, die nicht funktioniert. Also zum Beispiel Familien, die mit dem Phänomen von Radikalisierung so wenig anfangen können, dass sie nicht mehr sprechfähig sind. Also es gibt so ein Phänomen oder es gibt eine Beobachtung in dem Bereich von radikalisierten jungen Menschen im Bereich extremistischer Islamismus, da hat das Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge hat ein Nottelefon eingerichtet.
Und das wird hochfrequentiert von wem? Von den Müttern von jungen Menschen und von den Geschwistern. In der Regel den Schwestern. Das heißt Frauen rufen dort an und sagen, hier in meiner Familie ist etwas. Und jetzt machen wir Beobachtungen bei Distanzierungsarbeit und sehen, ein Teil der Radikalisierung schreitet schnell voran. Das ist ein irrsinniges wissenschaftlich hoch interessantes Phänomen, dass von der Ideologie, ich finde diese Form des extremistischen Terrorismus interessant bis zur Tat, die Radikalisierung ist wahnsinnig schnell. Es gibt eine Studie, 53% radikalisieren sich innerhalb von 12 Monaten. Muss man sich mal vorstellen, was da eigentlich passiert mit einem Menschen, 12 Monate von der Ideologie bis zum Dschihadisten. Das muss eigentlich jeder mitbekommen und genau das passiert in der Umwelt. Die Umwelt ist darauf nicht reaktions- und sprechfähig.
Weil sie die Merkmale, also die Anzeichen nicht wahrnimmt?
Sie nimmt die Anzeichen wahr, aber dann kommen Scham und Schuldgefühle dazu massiv. Das hätten wir eigentlich auch alles wissen müssen, weil wir haben im Bereich, wenn man sich anguckt den Bereich der Forschung Diskriminierung von Menschen mit Behinderung, Scham, Schuldgefühle, eigene Verantwortungszuschreibung, ich bin dafür verantwortlich, dass mein Kind ein Down-Syndrom hat. Das ist ja etwas, in den 70er Jahren hat das dazu geführt, dass auch Forschung gezeigt hat, dass diese massive Selbstzuschreibung von Verantwortung in Familien überhaupt nichts bringt, sondern eher dazu führt, dass Menschen mit Behinderung weiter diskriminiert werden und das finden wir jetzt hier in diesem Bereich auch. Und das ist in dem sozialen Umfeld, das sehen wir ja auch in ganz anderen Studien, wenn wir etwa in den Bereich der Vorurteilsstudien hineingucken, die wir durchführen.
Wir haben empirisch zeigen können, dass dort, wo extremistische Strukturen einsickern in bestimmte soziale Umfelder, das kann damit einhergehen, dass dort vor Ort aufgrund des massiven Problems Extremismus Zivilcourage einbricht. Es heißt, ja ich sehe, da gibt es so rechtsextreme Gruppen vor Ort, eine Zeit lang beschäftige ich mich damit, dann weiß ich alles über die, aber dadurch dass sie sich in der Umwelt verankern bricht dann Zivilcourage ein. Ich fange irgendwann an, das Problem weg zu ignorieren, um einfach mit diesem Problem auch umzugehen. Denn das ist natürlich, das weiß man aus der Forschung auch, wenn ein Kind sich radikalisiert, dann wird das von vielen wie eine Bedrohung empfunden. Ich habe versagt, ich habe als Eltern versagt, ich habe als Umwelt versagt, ich habe als Lehrerin/als Lehrer versagt und dieses Versagensgefühl führt zu Bedrohung und das führt dazu, dass wir dann anfangen uns blind zu stellen.
Und das am besten mal auszublenden. Und davon gewissermaßen lebt die Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung, dass ja Gesellschaften ständig Gewaltformen auch ausblenden oder versuchen, in irgendeiner Weise mit diesem Terror umzugehen. Indem sie dann daraus Terrorkulturen und so weiter machen.
Wir haben ja vorhin schon gesagt, Sie haben viel damit zu tun, falsche Wahrnehmung so in der Öffentlichkeit klarzustellen und überhaupt diese Erkenntnisse zu ermitteln. Sicherlich etwas was auch alle Wissenschaftler in ihren Felder auf ihre Art und Weise machen, nur hier glaube ich ist es nochmal besonders schwierig, weil es immer so ein gemein emotionales Thema noch dazu ist. Sie haben ja, das soll nicht unerwähnt bleiben, in diesem Jahr auch den Kommunikator-Preis erhalten von DFG und Stifterverband, der sozusagen auszeichnen soll, welche Kommunikation Sie so generell betreiben. Dass Sie jetzt sozusagen nicht nur so in Ihrem stillen Kämmerlein vor sich hinforschen und vielleicht alle drei Jahre mal in einem Podcast die Erkenntnisse teilen. Ganz im Gegenteil, Sie sind ganz gut unterwegs, ich glaube gerade derzeit bricht es alle Rekorde nehme ich mal an?
Ja im Moment, ich habe mich total verbaselt. Weil ich habe drei Geräte, auf denen ich einen Kalender eingerichtet habe und die habe ich schlecht synchronisiert. Ich habe tatsächlich gestern den 42. öffentlichen Vortrag in diesem Jahr gehalten, neben den 13 Projekten, neben der Lehre, neben den Beiratstätigkeiten, neben den Gutachten. Ich bin auch jetzt gleich schon wieder auf dem Weg in die nächste Sitzung, fahre dann zurück. Ich glaube ich weiß gar nicht, wie oft ich in Berlin war in diesem Jahr. Das hat mit dem Kommunikator-Preis eigentlich noch ganz wenig zu tun. Wir haben einfach in der Gesellschaft sehr viele Probleme, wo man dann bei uns anfragt, und der Kommunikator-Preis beschleunigt das Ganze vielleicht noch. Ja der Bedarf ist relativ hoch, ich habe keine Zeit, das genau zu analysieren, ob es nicht auch daran liegt, dass der Bereich der Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung vielleicht auch einfach noch mehr Leute bräuchte als mich.
Ich würde gerne die meisten Anfragen abgegeben an junge Leute, an andere Experten. Wir haben aber auch eine Zunahme der Kommunikationsgesellschaft. Also wir bewegen uns ja, unsere Gesellschaft bewegt sich ja in dem Bereich der Wissensvermittlung, des Wissenstransfer in einer ungeheuren Geschwindigkeit. Wenn ich mir angucke Bereiche der wissenschaftlichen Weiterbildung, wenn ich mir angucke Bereich der Onlinekommunikation, der virtuellen Kommunikation und so weiter, in die wir nun alle auch noch hineingeraten, dann beschleunigt sich das natürlich sehr stark. Und zum Teil auch Universitäten, weite Bereiche der Forschung fangen an, jetzt nochmal diese neuen Kommunikationsformen zu nutzen und da sind wir im Moment voll drin. Leider, ich glaube schon, es könnte noch viel mehr Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung brauchen, noch mehr Inseln in Deutschland. Weil natürlich Gewalt- und Konfliktregulation in modernen Gesellschaften ein ganz wesentlicher Weg ist für den sozialen Wandel.
Gibt es denn außer Ihrem Institut noch eine ähnliche spezialisierte Gruppe?
Ja. Naja es gibt eine ganze Reihe. Wir haben ja auch Grenzen. Jetzt bin ich ja im Bereich Konflikt-Gewalt-Forschung und Integrations-Migrations-Forschung, also dieses Feld käme noch hinzu, es gibt viele Gruppen. Ich war ja selbst in Jena und habe eine Professur vertreten, wo Gruppenkonfliktforschung gemacht wird. An der Uni Marburg, wir haben die hessische Stiftung Friedens-Konflikt-Forschung. Das Problem ist, im Moment werden wir bedeutsamer. Wir kooperieren und koordinieren uns zu wenig. Wir haben natürlich Bereiche der Wissenschaft, die sind hochgradig kompetitiv. Oh Gott da kommt jemand mit einer Studie raus vor uns, so läuft das ja auch ab. Ich halte das also für totalen Quatsch in dem Moment. Also wo alles angespannt ist, ist auch Wissenschaft umentspannt. Wir haben zu viel Wettbewerb. Wir müssten eigentlich mehr uns koordinieren und kooperieren.
Ich mach das meinen Leuten immer vor, die am meisten unter meiner Nichtanwesenheit wahrscheinlich leiden. Theoretisch könnte ich in jeder VHS in Deutschland einen Vortrag halten. In jeder Schule in Deutschland einen Vortrag halten, weil in jeder Schule im Moment Konflikt- und Gewaltphänomene natürlich auftauchen. In jeder politischen Partei, in jedem Medium und und und. Wenn man mal die Standorte zusammenzählen würde, das würde nicht reichen für ein Leben. Ist im Moment so.
Also sprich es gibt noch mehr Bedarf?
Es gibt neue Bereiche der Politikberatung, das wird sich auch öffnen. Das werden wir merken. Also wenn ich überblicke so die letzten 30 Jahre auch, es hat sich vieles professionalisiert auch im Bereich des Austausches von Forschung und Öffentlichkeit. Also nicht nur auf der Medienebene, sondern auch auf anderen Ebenen. Wenn wir in dem Bereich der Radikalisierung sind, da habe ich tatsächlich einen großen Vorteil, dass ich in Nordrhein-Westfalen beheimatet bin, weil gerade das Land diesen Bereich Integration und Migration, Konflikt und Bildung zusammen denkt, quer denkt. Wir auch zum Teil sehen im Bereich von Sicherheit. Wir haben einen Verfassungsschutzpräsidenten, der immer sagt, ich brauche die unabhängige Forschung, in die ich nicht hineinredigiere. Ich brauche die unabhängige Forschung. Und in Bielefeld die sind sehr weit. Wir wissen zum Beispiel jetzt mit Formen schwerster Gewalt, dadurch dass wir ein eigenes System der Kodierung von Information, die relevant sind, abzuschätzen, was sind die Ursachen und was sind die Prozesse.
Da sind wir relativ weit. Und wir haben das unabhängig von irgendwelchem Sicherheitsdruck entwickelt. Das ist etwas, wo man sieht, dass unabhängige Forschung, Grundlagenforschung auf einmal hochgradig bedeutsam wird für viele Bereiche. Also es gibt da einige Player. Ich würde mir wünschen, wir würden das mal irgendwie uns besser koordinieren. Es könnte aber auch mehr sein.
Mehr was sein?
Mehr Forschungsinseln.
Mehr Forschungsinseln ja.
Also ich träume davon. Ich werde auch nicht müde, das immer wieder zu sagen, ich bin bereit, dieses Institut in Bielefeld auszubauen. Ich habe gute Leute, die Möglichkeit der Arbeitsvertraggestaltung ist für mich suboptimal. Das heißt ich muss die guten Leute, die exzellenten Leute versuchen bei mir zu halten und dabei habe ich große Schwierigkeiten. Weil wenn wir im Bereich der schweren Gewalt der Kriminalität sind, dann werden die auch abgeworben in Behörden hinein. Und die möchten das auch, weil die auch irgendwann mal Familie gründen wollen und weil die sehen, ich arbeite pensionsberechtigt, das ist wunderbar, aber Wissenschaft ist ein Eisberg. Da oben ist nur Platz für wenige, das ist ein harter Kampf. Es dauert relativ lange, man wird dabei sehr alt und verliert auch seine privaten Netzwerke. Der Preis ist hoch. Und da gibt es jetzt viele Felder im Bereich auch von Wirtschaft und so weiter, die ziehen die Leute weg.
Weil natürlich auch zum Beispiel, wenn wir eine exzellente Radikalisierungsforschung machen, ist das hochgradig interessant für Unternehmen. Weil ja der Bereich Dschihadismus, die radikalisierten Leute, die sitzen ja nicht nur bei uns an den Universitäten, sondern die sind dann eben auch in den Firmen. Also haben Firmen jetzt eigene Programme dort aufbereitet und da verschwinden die. Und da bräuchte ich eine andere Unterstützung und ich träume schon davon, so ein relativ großes Zentrum zu haben mit vielen Professoren, die befristet dann bei uns die Projekte machen, aber eben Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung und das mal im großen Stil und nicht nur durch eine Aggregierung von einzelnen Projekten. Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass wir in Bielefeld fähig sind, so eine große Nummer mal zu stemmen. Aber man braucht ja immer so eine Vision und so ein Ziel, um auch noch weiter zu machen.
Kommen wir nochmal auf die Kommunikation auf eine andere Art und Weise. Jetzt ist ja schon klar geworden, es gibt auch einen guten Grund, warum gerade Ihre Expertise so gefragt ist, weil Deutschland einfach ja bis zum Hals in dieser Debatte der Radikalisierung steckt. Sowohl der Radikalisierung als Bedrohungsszenario, Stichwort Islamisierung. Viele neue Menschen kommen zu uns und sind halt potenziell gefährdet, hier auch von Gruppen angesprochen zu werden, bis hin zu der Angst, dass sie schon radikalisiert hier auflaufen, was sicherlich eher die Minderheit sein dürfte. Aber auf der anderen Seite haben wir es auch mit einer Radikalisierung der eigenen Bevölkerung zu tun. Und in gewisser Hinsicht auch mit einer Aufspaltung. Erst gab es die starken Widerstände. Dann gab es den Widerstand gegen den Widerstand.
Dann hat sich Deutschland für einen Herbst wiedergefunden vereint in großer Freunde- und Menschenliebe. Was sich aber angesichts der fortwährenden Anschläge auf Flüchtlingsheime etc. Demonstrationen und natürlich auch generell eine Radikalisierung der politischen Debatte noch nicht so richtig wieder eingefangen hat. Man fragt sich natürlich, warum kann das so überhaupt passieren? Bzw. was passiert eigentlich gerade? Was treibt insbesondere Ostdeutschland, aber nicht nur, um? Welche Ängste werden hier berührt und wie kann man dem begegnen?
Wir machen ja jetzt seit 14 Jahren diese Studien zum Thema gruppenbezogene Menschenfeindlichkeit. Das heißt da geht es vor allen Dingen darum, dass wir von 2002 bis 2011 jedes Jahr – damals hat die Studie Wilhelm Heitmeyer geleitet am IKG, also am Institut für interdisziplinäre Konflikt- und Gewaltforschung – 2002 bis 2011 in jedem Jahr repräsentative Umfragen gemacht, in denen wir die Frage gestellt haben, warum bewerten Menschen andere Gruppen in der Gesellschaft als ungleichwertig? Wohnungslose, Frauen, Menschen mit homosexueller Orientierung und so weiter. Jetzt geht es um Vorurteilsdiskriminierungsmuster und wir haben zeitgleich immer gemessen und erfasst, was sind zentrale gesellschaftliche Fragen, was sind politische Meinungen. Aus diesen Datenerhebungen kriegt man einiges heraus darüber, wie jetzt solche populistischen Bewegungen entstehen. Jetzt machen wir das im Zweijahresabstand mit Unterstützung der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung.
Wenn man in diese Daten hineinguckt, dann sehen wir auf der einen Seite, ja es gibt gesellschaftliche soziale Prozesse, die das erzeugen. Wie zum Beispiel, das fand ich mal eine sehr faszinierende Analyse von Kollegen, in ostdeutschen ländlichen Regionen die Abwanderung von bildungsstarken Gruppen führt dazu, dass sich politisch polarisierte Meinung, antidemokratische Meinungen und menschenfeindliche Meinungen erhöhen. In Regionen, wo Rechtsextremismus sich verankert, steigt das Ausmaß der Wahrnehmung, das ist normal. Das ist so ein Effekt. Zweiter Effekt ist, diese populistischen Bewegungen, Pegida und so weiter, können sich dann bilden, wenn massiv Demokratievertrauen einbricht. Das ist ein ganz wesentlicher Moment gewesen in Ostdeutschland. Also in den fünf neuen Bundesländern.
Wir haben gesehen, diese Bundesländer, die im Moment wieder dramatisch auftauchen mit höheren menschenfeindlichen und rechtsextremen Einstellungen. Also diese Ost-West-Differenz ist wieder da, die lange weg war. Die war ja gar nicht so, wir hatten eher einen Einigungsprozess. Das heißt man ist so gesamtdeutsch antisemitischer, islamfeindlicher geworden und so weiter. Aber wir haben diese Differenz, weil es unterschiedliche Kulturen immer noch gibt. Wir sehen in den Daten das Ausmaß nicht individueller Deprivation, mir geht es schlechter, ich habe Sorgen, ich steige ab, sondern es ist eine kollektive Deprivation. Wir nennen das Konzept der kollektiven relativen Deprivation, ist uralt. Ted Gore, ein berühmter amerikanischer Wissenschaftler hat gesagt, soziale Protestbewegungen entstehen aus kollektiven Deprivationen. Wenn ich das Gefühl habe, wir hier steigen ab, wir nehmen auch nicht teil am Wohlstand. Wir haben ja eine soziale Spaltung in der Gesellschaft.
Das ist ja definitiv so und man kann das ja nicht mehr wegreden, es ist ja kaum noch möglich, weil die Daten zugänglich sind, dass wir eine Polarisierung, auch eine soziale in der Gesellschaft haben. Wir haben reiche Gegenden, prosperierende Gegenden, Wohlstandsnachbarschaften, Gated Communities wie in Amerika. Douglas Massey, Kollege der mit und zusammenarbeitet, nennt das The New American Apartheid. Die weiße Oberklasse, die sich da abschottet. Das wird auch medial immer deutlicher. Das lässt sich einfach eben nicht mehr weg ignorieren. Das führt dazu. Und dann gibt es auch noch viel stärker, wir hatten das 2005/2006 schon gemessen in den Studien, wir haben in fünf neuen Bundesländern selbst so das Phänomen, wir sind Bürger zweiter Klasse. Also diese Idee, wir gehören eigentlich nicht nur zu den Verlierern, sondern wir sind ungleichwertig, wir sind ungleich wert, wir sind Bürger zweiter Klasse.
Und auf der anderen Seite die Idee, dass eigentlich Gemeinschaft nur durch homogene gleiche Meinungen gebildet werden kann, das ist ein extrem guter Nährboden für Populismus. Der funktioniert aber nur dann, Pegida auch Teile des eher rassistischen Zweiges in der AfD funktioniert nur, wenn ich eine Propagandamaschinerie habe, die jetzt diese Meinungen von Menschen überführen kann in einen Zustand von einem Gefühl der Ohnmacht, der kollektiven Ohnmacht. Wir erleben all das, wir erleben die Spaltung, die Risse, das nicht mehr gehört werden, die politischen Eliten die in Berlin sitzen und lauter Entscheidungen treffen, an denen wir überhaupt nicht teilhaben. Nicht nur nicht teilhaben, unter denen wir vermeintlich leiden, ohne beteiligt zu werden, führt dazu, dass es Demokratiemisstrauen gibt. Das wird überführt in eine Ohnmacht.
Ich würde ja ganz gerne mehr Macht haben, aber ich bin total ohnmächtig. Und in dem Moment kann der Populismus eigentlich zugreifen, indem er ein sehr deutliches leichtes Heilsversprechen macht. Indem er zum Beispiel, und das sehen in den Daten, dieses Leitbild nationaler Chauvinismus, wir zuerst. Wir haben eine sehr schöne Studie durchgeführt mit Förderung der Stiftung Mercator, die heißt Zugehörigkeit und Gleichwertigkeit. Da geht es eigentlich um Integrationsvorstellungen. Wollen wir eher Integration von Zugewanderten oder sollen die sich erst mal assimilieren. Und in dieser Studie haben wir 14/15, das war genau der Moment, wo Pegida, die ja gegründet wurden ohne die großen Fluchtbewegungen, das vergessen wir immer. Die Facebook-Seite war vor der Fluchtbewegung. Die aber dann da zuschlagen konnte aus diesem Zustand gesellschaftlicher Verunsicherung Kapital ziehen konnte. In diesem Moment haben in der Studie repräsentativ über 60% gesagt, jetzt ist es eigentlich Zeit, dass unsere Tradition, dass wir mal wieder an erster Stelle stehen.
Das sind genau die Momente, wo gesellschaftliches geht wieder etwas, dann wollen alle teilhaben. Sie wollen also bei dem Verteilungswettbewerb jetzt auch mal mit partizipieren und sagen, jetzt sind wir dran. Und in dem Moment kriegt man vermittelt, durch die Zuwanderung kommen aber vielleicht neue Belastungen. Und das ist stark für den Populismus, weil in dem Moment fühlen sich Menschen ohnmächtig, wollen Macht, wollen Einfluss und dann greift das zu. Und in dieser Bewegung, das finde ich jetzt als Phänomen auch hochgradig interessant, wenn man da genau beobachtet, wir sind da ins Feld gegangen, wir haben uns das alles genau angeguckt, wer ist denn da eigentlich, wer steht denn da zusammen, gründet sich eine Bewegung deshalb, weil man sagt, man kommuniziert gar nicht. Man hat eine bestimmte politische Ideologie, die teilt man. Man hat eine bestimmte kollektive gemeinsame Identität. Man weiß, dass man dort aus lauter Personen besteht, die eigentlich im Alltag vielleicht gar nicht so gut miteinander zurechtkommen würden.
Da sind Menschen, die glauben an Konspirationsmythen. Da sind andere, die kommen aus der alten Antifa. Da sind wieder andere, die kommen aus der rechtsextremen Bewegung. Da sind wieder besorgte Bürger drin und so weiter. Das ist eine ganz heterogene Gruppe. Und in der Bewegung sagt man, wir akzeptieren euch alle. Wir sind aber geeint in einem nationalen Chauvinismus. In dem Moment haben wir uns Gedanken gemacht, und zwar im Bereich der Migrations-, Integrationsforschung haben wir eins gesehen, gesellschaftlich nicht angehört in dem Moment, auch von politischen Eliten nicht angehört, werden Menschen, die selber Migration erfahren haben. Die sich auch als Bürger zweiter Klasse empfinden. Und wir haben uns dann die Frage gestellt in der Migrationsforschung, was fehlt eigentlich im Land, um jetzt diese massiven Spannungen, Anspannungen, Konflikte, Ohnmachtsgefühle und so weiter zu regulieren. Warum eskaliert das im Moment?
Denn die Zahl der Straftaten nahm zu. Die Symbole, das habe ich nun als Gewaltforscher relativ schnell gesagt 2014 und dafür viel Ärger gekriegt, die Symbole waren von Anfang an bei den sogenannten Montagsspaziergängen extrem aggressions- und gewaltorientiert. Also wenn man die Ikonographie anguckt dessen was auf den Plakaten und so weiter gezeigt wird, drängte das damals schon zur Aggression.
Was meinen Sie jetzt?
Ja, eines der Symbole, ich nenne nur mal zwei Beispiele, die immer da waren war ein schwarz rot gold eingefärbtes Kreuz. Das wurde immer vorweg getragen. Und wenn man dieses Symbol tatsächlich vorweg trägt und sagt, das ist unsere Identifikationsfolie, weiß man als Konfliktforscher, hier sind Leute unterwegs, also nationales Christentum ist eigentlich so etwas, was nur provozieren kann und nur letztendlich zum Konflikt führt. Es war immer zu sehen ein Schweinskopf und da war das Gesicht von Frau Merkel rein projiziert, das wurde auch immer vorweg getragen. So ein Kredo war ja, Merkel muss weg.
Alle die zuhören, vielleicht immer wieder, nein ich werde von Frau Merkel nicht dafür bezahlt, dass ich das jetzt nenne, das ist auch so ein Konspirationsmythos, der schnell aufgelegt wird, man darf nichts positives und so weiter. Aber das wurde gezeigt und das ist ja, eine Kanzlerin projiziert auf einen Schweinskopf im öffentlichen Raum, ist zunächst mal ein Hinweisreiz auf Molly. Wir gehen weit, wir reizen das jetzt auf. Ein aufgespießter. Wenn man das so sieht. Und das sind die Situationen, wo wir gesagt haben, was fehlt hier eigentlich? Warum eskaliert das? Warum radikalisiert sich das? Ohne dass die Leute es merken, wir merken Radikalisierung nicht individuell. Wir laufen da einfach mit und denken, ist doch alles irgendwie gut. Und da schreien die ja vorneweg, keine Gewalt, keine Gewalt. Also in der Betonung, keine Gewalt, da würde ja jeder Kommunikationswissenschaftler wahre Freude dran haben.
Ja ist auch immer noch.
Und würde sagen, was wird denn da kommuniziert. Also offensichtlich haben die ein Wissen, dass da irgendwie Gewalt im Raum ist, sonst würden die ja nicht rufen, keine Gewalt. Also man schreit immer genau gegen das an, wo man selbst ein Problem hat. Islamisierung und nationales Christentum, also schwarz rot goldenes Kreuz geht ja natürlich für einen evangelischen Theologen überhaupt nicht. Also diese Ambivalenz, was fehlt da eigentlich? Warum gibt es keine Mäßigung? Und da kamen wir auf die Idee zusammen im Rat für Migration, der besteht ja aus über 130 Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler, viele mit einer Migrationsbiografie, was hier fehlt ist ein alternatives Leitbild. Das hätte jetzt sein können der von Habermas, dem berühmten Soziologen, proklamierter Verfassungspatriotismus, aber offensichtlich Verfassungspatriotismus, Identifikation über dieses gesellschaftliche Leitbild funktioniert nicht.
Einwanderungsgesellschaft. Wir sehen jetzt in den empirischen Daten, wir werden es am 07. Juli veröffentlichen, interessant ist ein alternatives Bild, war dann in Gesellschaft Willkommenskultur, da bildeten sich Gemeinschaften. Aber das Land hat schon vermisst so ein alternatives Leitbild einem nationalen Chauvinimus gegenüber zu stellen, das hat es vermisst. Das haben aber auch die etablierten Parteien, vielleicht in ihrer Gemütlichkeit, wird schon irgendwie funktionieren, vollkommen vergessen.
Versäumt, und das sehen wir eigentlich in den Daten und haben dann dieses auch zur Diskussion gestellt. Und haben gesagt, so damit gehen wir jetzt, mit diesem Befund gehen wir jetzt an die Öffentlichkeit und versuchen dadurch eben auf der Grundlage von Forschungsevidenz auch öffentlichen Debatten zu initiieren, zum Teil auch zu provozieren. Auch das ist ja interessant.
Versäumt eins bereitzustellen?
Also Sie meinen jetzt konkret, dass man zum Beispiel so sagt, okay wir postulieren jetzt hier Verfassungspatriotismus und Stolz aufs Grundgesetz oder wie man das auch immer nennen soll und stellen das sozusagen jetzt in dem Moment in der Debatte als alternatives Leitbild zur Verfügung?
Ja.
Und welche berücksichtigt das diese fünf Motivationsgruppen?
Es gibt ja verschiedene. Ich würde das jetzt von mir aus, ich habe immer gesagt, ich stelle gerne das Wissen bereit über den Zustand. Wir haben ja diese Reihe herausgegeben, Wilhelm Heitmeyer hat die ja rausgegeben, deutsche Zustände. Jetzt publizieren wir das weiter. Vor zwei Jahren hieß es fragile Zustände, demnächst kommt ein neues Buch, gespaltene Mitte, raus. Ich stelle die Bilder mal bereit, die wir in den Wahrnehmungen der Menschen sehen, das ist ja schon mal sehr viel wert, dass wir … Das ist ja auch eine interessante Facette, wenn wir über Kommunikation und Wissenschaft reden. Eigentlich ist Gesellschaft sehr gut repräsentiert in dem was wir in wissenschaftlicher Forschung haben. Ich sage das den Leuten immer, die mich angreifen, die sagen, wir werden ja nicht gehört. Also in unserer Studien in Bielefeld, wir ohne ansehen der Person reden ja mit allen. Und in diesen Studien ist repräsentiert Meinung, Wahrnehmung, das sollte die Leute entspannen. Aber gut, nicht ihre Meinung ist da repräsentiert, das meinen sie dann.
Aber wir stellen das bereit. Ich glaube ja, dass es funktionieren kann, aber das Problem, jetzt kommt der Psychologe in mir durch, dieser Verfassungspatriotismus greift offensichtlich nicht auf einer emotionalen Ebene, da muss etwas anderes dazukommen. Also da muss vielleicht so etwas, das muss gepaart sein mit Anerkennungskultur. Wir haben sehr viel Untersuchung gemacht im Bereich, wie nehmen Menschen, die aktiv in Unterkünften sich engagieren, Willkommenskultur wahr und dann stellen wir oft fest, viele treibt doch tatsächlich – ich habe das auch am Anfang nicht geglaubt oder nicht vorhergesehen – viele sagen, wir brauchen mehr Anerkennung. Und jetzt könnte man wieder in die Anerkennungsforschung hineingucken, könnte da mal nachgucken. Honett hat gesagt, was brauchen wir im Kollektiv, in einer Gemeinschaft an Anerkennung? Liebe, Gerechtigkeit und Solidarität.
Das heißt zum Verfassungspatriotismus muss das kommen. Eine andere Variante wäre eben das Leitbild einer Einwanderungsgesellschaft, einer Gesellschaft, das sagt ja Naika Foroutan von der Humboldt-Universität Berlin, eine postmigrantische Gesellschaft in Bielfeld. Thomas Faist ein Migrationsforscher sagt, dass eigentlich die post-, die transnationale Gesellschaft, die New Citizenship, das ist eigentlich ein Leitbild. Die kommunalen Citizenships. Und jetzt sehen wir, man muss bei dieser Leitbilddiskussion, die wir jetzt initiiert haben, weil da finden jetzt überall Dialoge statt, ganz unabhängig von uns, zum Thema Leitbild. Auch im Kanzleramt wurde das diskutiert und so weiter. Was setzen wir dem politisch jetzt als Leitbild. Wir müssen zunehmend sehen, dabei müssen wir berücksichtigen, wo wir gerade Leitbild diskutieren, denn wir haben Ungleichzeitigkeit in Gesellschaft. Im urbanen Raum in Berlin, wo wir beide gerade sitzen, ist vielleicht etwas ganz anderes interessanter, um Konflikte zu regulieren, als es im ländlichen Raum ist.
Im ländlichen Raum, wo wir eben gar keine migrantische Gesellschaft haben. Die ungleichzeitig ist oder in Bereichen, wo wir uns erst mal darum kümmern müssen, wie können wir mehr Menschen, die eine Migrationsbiografie haben, in einen Zustand von Gleichwertigkeit bringen. Das wird ja so massiv im Moment auch über Gebiete, neue Ghettos diskutiert. Da ist der Populismus ja extrem erfolgreich, indem er wieder immer wieder eine bahnbrechende These in den Raum stellt und wir uns alle daran abarbeiten, ob diese These nun stimmt oder nicht. Wo ich immer denke, das ist irgendwie…
Jede Woche eine neue Sau, die durchs Dorf getrieben wird.
Ja und dann sage ich da auch noch was zu und dann denkt man immer selber, mein Gott man treibt es eigentlich voran, indem man da mitmacht und das auch noch kommentiert. Was weiß ich, wenn der Gauland jetzt über Boateng redet und dann wieder sagt, er hat aber gar nicht, und er kennt ihn ja gar nicht, er wusste gar nicht welche Hautfarbe und dann wird der Wissenschaftler angerufen und um eine Definition von Rassismus gebeten. In dem Moment denke ich, ja es gibt das Bedürfnis Rassismus zu verstehen und ich definiere das ja auch sehr gerne, das ist unsere Aufgabe und es wäre gut, mehr Leute wüssten was Rassismus ist, weil ich sehe, dass die meisten Leute überhaupt nicht wissen, dass sie rassistisch sich äußern, obwohl sie es tun. Das will ich ihnen ja nicht zuschreiben, sondern da muss ich eben aufklären, dass das was sie gerade machen eben auch anders geht. Also man muss nicht rassistisch argumentieren. Das kann man verlernen. Wir verlangen von unseren Kindern in den Schulen, dass sie das nicht sind und dann verlassen wir die Schule und dürfen oder wie? Nein.
Dann diskutiert man drüber und ist Teil dieser ganzen medialen Inszenierung und der ganzen medialen Kommunikation und veredelt das Ganze. Das ist die Gratwanderung, die im Moment extrem schwierig ist. Die interessantere Diskussion ist eigentlich, haben wir alternativ, attraktive Gesellschaftsbilder, die Menschen dazu bringen, leichtfertig nicht zu glauben, sondern eher sie mitnehmen in das, was wir als Zivilgesellschaft haben. Wir sehen in unseren Daten über viele Jahre, dass zwar das Interesse, sich auch politisch zu partizipieren, relativ groß ist, aber mehr Menschen sich daraus zurückziehen. Letzte große Erhebung, fragile Mitte haben wir das genannt, 14/15 zeigt, das Meinungsbild, die Überzeugungsmuster, die Ursachen, warum andere Menschen andere abwerten, bei Nichtwählerinnen und Nichtwählern ist sehr ähnlich denen von AfD-Sympathisanten.
Das kann man empirisch zeigen, indem man eben die Meinung identifiziert, die Überzeugungsmuster und dann miteinander vergleicht. Und das wirft natürlich jetzt für eine Gesellschaft extrem wichtige Fragen auf. Aber hier wird es in Berlin anders diskutiert als in Bielefeld, anders als in Stuttgart, anders als in Bayern. Das sind unterschiedliche lokale Kulturen. Wenn man das miteinander verbinden könnte wäre es wunderbar.
Kann man ja. Gibt ja Internet und da müssen wir glaube ich auch mal drauf zu sprechen kommen. Gut mittlerweile ist das ja alles nicht mehr neu, also wenn man jetzt vielleicht mal Bundesregierung rausnimmt, für die ist das ja alles noch neu, aber das Netz hat sich schon seinen Raum geschaffen. Das ist ein Prozess, der wird wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Weile lang so weitergehen, aber man kann auf jeden Fall feststellen, die digitale Kommunikation ist in zunehmendem Maße ein Teil der Gesellschaft geworden. Und damit ändert sie natürlich auch diese regionalen, lokalen Bezüge. Es gibt auf einmal eine neue Region. Es gibt so die Region Netz, über die sich auch Gruppen jetzt zu finden scheinen, die bisher nicht unbedingt jetzt durch besonders überregionale Aktivität aufgefallen ist. Also so ein bisschen so der virtuelle Stammtisch.
Der auf einmal nicht nur so aus acht Leuten besteht, sondern vielleicht auf einmal aus 80, 800, 8000 oder mehr. Und auch für mich so als alten Netzbegleiter ist das sehr interessant, dass hier sozusagen auf einmal eine Gruppe sich der Werkzeuge bemächtigt und sie zum Einsatz bringt, die man bisher nicht unbedingt so auf dem Zeiger hatte, wenn man über die Auswirkung des Internets auf den gesellschaftlichen Diskurs diskutiert hat. Da war ja gerade am Anfang viel von so einem utopischen Weltbild dort, wo man gesagt hat, okay, jetzt kommen hier die klugen Leute zusammen. Schon wie Albert Einstein das vor 100 Jahren gesagt hat, die Völker erwachen aus schläfriger Stumpfheit, weil sie jetzt auf einmal Radiokommunikation haben.
Und irgendwie, wenn man aber jetzt gerade mal so da den Lackmusstreifen reinhält hat man eher so das Gefühl, dass die schläfrige Stumpfheit sozusagen zwar erwacht, aber nicht unbedingt schärfer geworden ist. Wie beobachten Sie das, was spielt das Netz für eine Rolle, was spielt die digitale Kommunikation für eine Rolle, auch konkret jetzt in dieser Pegida, AfD Situation? Ich meine, auf der einen Seite sehen wir vieles, was wir früher schon mal gesehen haben, auf der anderen Seite macht es eben so den Eindruck, als expandiert es enorm, unter anderem eben auch durch diese Netzkommunikation.
Na das interessante, Sie nennen jetzt Pegida. Ich würde die jetzt als populistische Bewegung bezeichnen, mit starken Armen in den Rechtsextremismus und so weiter, das will ich aber gar nicht weiter definieren. Sehr heterogen, das Interessante ist, was ist denn besser für Populisten als ein Medium zu nutzen, was den ganzen Populismus technisch wie aber auch sprachlich, linguistisch wie aber auch für den Bereich der Organisation einer Bewegung wunderbar zulässt. Was haben wir gesehen bei Pegida? Wir haben uns Pegida gewidmet, wo wir Radikalisierungsprozesse im Bereich islamistischer Extremismus beobachtet haben. Was wir dort schon seit längerem beobachten, die Terrorismusforschung macht das schon noch viel länger, ist, der Bereich Internet ist mittlerweile ja multifunktional.
auf der einen Seite Information. Der Terrorismus, in den terroristischen Gruppen wird das Internet genutzt, um Informationen bereitzustellen. Aber in diesem Internet, wenn wir den Bereich Terror angucken, haben wir eine komplette Nachrichtenindustrie. Wir haben eine komplette Rekrutierungsindustrie, wir haben eine Mobilisierungsindustrie. Wir haben Communities, die sich abbilden. Das heißt es passiert etwas in der Welt, es passiert ein Anschlag und über das Internet wird die Community gebildet. Das ist in vielen Bereichen auch. Ich nenne mal einen ganz positiven Bereich, nämlich der Flüchtlingshilfe der Zivilgesellschaft. Das ist ja keine Bewegung und keine Gruppe und keine Partei. Aber wie das organisiert ist, das hat sich organisiert übers Internet und nicht mehr über die klassischen Medien. Und klar, weil alle technischen Möglichkeiten sind da.
Bei Pegida war es sehr interessant, wir haben das mal analysiert zusammen mit Linguisten, die da unterwegs sind. Montags geht man spazieren, Montagnacht werden die Informationen über den Spaziergang gepostet. Am Dienstag wird die Nachlese gemacht, die Informationen für alle, die nicht mit Spazierengehen. Die Bilder, aber auch die neuen Informationen lanciert. Zu Beginn waren das Netzaktivisten, 25000-30000. Am Mittwoch hat man gesehen, welche politischen Felder im Internet jetzt bedient werden. Ist das Thema Heimat im Moment wichtig. Am Donnerstag wird angekündigt, was am Montag passiert, Gastredner lädt man ein, die werden im Internet verbreitet, gepostet und so weiter. Das heißt diese ganze Onlinekommunikation ist ein Teil, ein ganz wesentlicher Bestandteil von diesen sozialen Bewegungen.
Und das haben wir in vielen Bereichen. Der ganze Bereich, ich könnte jetzt in komplett andere Bereiche gehen, wie kommen eigentlich Migrantinnen und Migranten jetzt durch die Welt? Online.
Auch mit dem Smartphone.
Online mit dem Smartphone. Ich habe gestern eine interessante Veranstaltung gemacht eben zur Stadtentwicklung, wo ein Architekt vorgestellt hat, wie kann man Flüchtlingen besser helfen, ihre Lebenssituation zu bewältigen? Der den interessanten Vorschlag gemacht hat, naja man baut Notinseln im Meer aus Altmüll und so weiter, ganz faszinierende Ideen und dann hat er gesagt, was brauchen die Leute dort vor Ort? Sie brauchen eine Steckdose, um das Smartphone aufzuladen und sie brauchen einen Sonnenschutz, weil die meisten Krankheiten sind Verbrennungen bei der Flucht über das Meer. Und da merkt man, das ist das was da gebraucht wird. Und wir sehen jetzt im Bereich, ich bin kein Medienwissenschaftler, aber ich lese das und ich bin ja auch im Kuratorium der Civis Medienstiftung, die Civis Medienstiftung lobt Preise aus für alle journalistischen Formate, die sich mit Integration und Migration beschäftigen. Ist gerade verliehen worden der Civis Medienpreis.
Ich sitze da dankenswerterweise mit im Kuratorium und dort beschäftigen wir uns natürlich auch mit der Frage, welche Bedeutung haben Medien. Ich lese dazu sehr viel. Ich stelle jetzt fest, dass unter jungen Menschen die Grenze zwischen analoger und digitaler entfallen ist. Das heißt wir haben zum Teil Studien, die zeigen, ich kann im Internet mich verlieben und ich kann da auch Schluss machen und emotional hat es die gleiche Qualität wie in der analogen Welt. Und da sehen wir nun, dass sich dort etwas tut. Wir sehen, wir haben schon in den 90er Jahren darauf hingewiesen, dass in extremistischen Bewegungen wir mehr Webseiten haben als in den sogenannten Gegenbewegungen der sogenannten Zivilgesellschaft. Wir haben im Bereich, ich nenne das immer wieder, weil ich da aktuell drinstehe, islamistischer Extremismus mehr und bessere Seiten für Jugendliche, die sind popkulturell, die haben alles was Jugendliche brauchen.
Im Gegensatz zu altbackenen Webseiten islamischer Vereine und Gemeinden. Auf denen kein Mensch mehr rumsurft, der ein bisschen jünger ist. Und da sieht man, die Grenzen sind schwimmend, wir sind in der Forschung, da würde ich mir wünschen, müssten wir mehr Kompetenzen besitzen. Wir haben junge Forscherinnen und Forscher, die jetzt auch die Netzwelten für Forschungszwecke nutzen. Und zwar nicht nur mit traditionellen Onlinestudien, sondern indem man das Netz selber beforscht und auch netzaffine Methoden entwickelt. Also da sind wir ja auch mittlerweile sehr weit.
Mussten die vielleicht auch erst überhaupt einmal eine netzaffine Grundhaltung einstellen an den Universitäten? Ich meine, wir leben immer noch in so einer Zeit, wo das Internet so ein bisschen eher als Bedrohung und Nebensächlichkeit wahrgenommen wird. Wenn man das da so erlebt.
Naja immerhin haben wir jetzt an der Uni Bielefeld, wir sitzen in einem Neubau, dem sogenannten X-Gebäude, weil die Uni wird renoviert, wird komplett fast entkernt und wieder aufgebaut. Immerhin sehe ich jetzt in den neuen Hörsälen, da ist an jedem Arbeitsplatz eine Steckdose. Das ist eine Veränderung von räumlichen Umwelten. Es kommt natürlich dazu, dass sie nicht nur die Notebooks aufladen.
Strom oder Ethernet?
Es ist wunderschön, ich habe meine erste Veranstaltung da gemacht und da kam ein junger Mann und der belegte gleich sechs Steckdosen mit sechs Handys. Da habe ich gesagt, das ist eine neue Aneignung. Wir denken eigentlich, er soll dort ordentlich sein Notebook aufladen. Nein klar natürlich, da sind wir weit hinterher. Ich gucke so in Bereiche der wissenschaftlichen Weiterbildung, die jetzt das digitale Netz sehr viel anders nutzen, auch für Formen der Bildung. Kann man besser nutzen. Ich habe eine wunderschöne Veranstaltung gemacht, da war ich selber beeindruckt als ich da saß. Wir haben eine Onlineveranstaltung, nicht einen Vortrag vor Ort gemacht, sondern eine Onlineveranstaltung mit den Volkshochschulen in Deutschland. Wo ich digital saß und ein sehr schönes Programm hatte und diskutieren konnte. Das heißt ich konnte gleichzeitig diskutieren mit Menschen, die jetzt irgendwo an der polnischen Grenze saßen oder an der Schweizer Grenze saßen, also vollkommen weit voneinander entfernt und wir haben über Rechtspopulismus geredet.
Die Leute konnten sich einbringen und vor Ort ihre Geschichte erzielen. Und da hat man die ganzen kulturellen Differenzen gesehen. Das sind digitale Möglichkeiten, die ja nun, ich bin ja auch ein bisschen älter, alles begreife ich nicht und werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht können und so. Soziale Netzwerke, das ist etwas, wir beschäftigen uns am Institut damit, nutzen wir das. Aber da kommen wir auch an Grenzen. Jetzt muss ich auch deutlich sagen, dass wir in manchen Bereichen der Nutzung von sozialen Netzwerken einfach deswegen überhaupt nicht unterwegs sind, weil wir bei unserer Forschung immer auf die Rechte und Bedürfnisse derjenigen achten müssen, mit denen wir reden. Also der Schutz von Privatsphäre, gerade wenn es um Phänomene geht von Konflikt und Gewalt, der ist ein hohes Gut. Ich muss auch noch fähig sein und die Möglichkeit haben, mit Menschen zusammen zu reden und Interviews zu führen, die eben selbst sehr stark extremismusanfällig sind.
Und dann kann ich nicht alles herausposaunen und will ich auch überhaupt nicht über die sozialen Netzwerke. Interessanterweise ist es ja für mich, wir brauchen digitale Kompetenzen. Und die erste digitale Kompetenz im Bereich von Forschung ist bei uns natürlich das Filtern von wichtigem, relevantem und irrelevantem. Das Wichtige ist, unter dem wir immer noch leiden, wenn ich daran denke, wie ich meine Diplomarbeit geschrieben habe und damals per Fernleihe Artikel von Primärliteratur in Amerika bestellt habe. Und in der Organisation meiner Diplomarbeit wusste, ich bestelle jetzt diesen Artikel und es braucht drei Wochen, bis ich den gedruckt bekomme und dann kann ich auf einen Artikel gucken. Heute kann ich binnen 10 Sekunden mit einer Recherche 200 Artikel mir downloaden. Was aber heute dazu bedeutet, dass ich eben querlese und nur noch kurz reingucke. Die Abstracts angucke und so weiter.
Da die Kompetenz zu besitzen, wieder einen Schritt zurückzugehen. Also nicht zehn Schritte vorauszulaufen, weil das Medium es so verlangt, sondern auch zehn Schritte zurückzugehen, das ist eigentlich die große Kompetenz.
Ja es verleitet schnell zu quantitativen Ansätzen, wo qualitative besser wären.
Wenn wir angucken den Bereich der empirischen Zahlen, die wir im Raum haben. Wenn ich jetzt öffentlich kommuniziere ist es doch vollkommen klar, das Interesse ist immer, nennen Sie maximal drei Prozentzahlen und dann ist Schluss. Weil bei Konflikt-Gewalt wir werden gefragt und wenn wir nichts dramatisches zu berichten haben, entweder massive Anstiege oder irgendetwas ist massiv gesunken, sind wir dann im öffentlichen Bereich der Kommunikation nicht mehr. Dann auch Wissenschaft gerät durch die neuen digitalen Medien natürlich in eine riesige Zwickmühle. Ich habe jetzt verfolgt, da gab es das große Thema, zu dem ich dann auch befragt wurde und wo ich zum Glück gesagt habe, ich kann wissenschaftlich exakt zuverlässiges nicht sagen. Und ich möchte das im Moment auch noch nicht, bitte geben Sie mir Zeit, das selbst zu recherchieren. Weil der Bereich Gewalt gegen Christen in Flüchtlingsunterkünften.
Das war auf einmal in der Welt und dann habe ich mir angeguckt, naja mich überrascht es nicht, dass es das gibt. Also ich halte alle möglichen Gewaltformen für wenig überraschend, auch Kölner Silvesternacht oder so. Mit so etwas ist für mich einfacher vielleicht nachzuvollziehen, dass so was passiert als wenn ich da selber das aus einer Betroffenen-Perspektive angucke und so weiter. Aber jetzt bei diesem Thema Gewalt gegen Christen in Flüchtlingsunterkünften das ging durch die Welt rasend schnell und es stand immer dabei, eine Studie zeigt. Und dann kommt eben ein bisschen später raus, ja die Menschen, die die Studie gemacht haben, haben das in einer Unterkunft analysiert und dann ist es medial hochgepoppt, als wenn es überall in den Unterkünften ist, und dann müssen die Forscherinnen und Forscher zurückrudern und das ist natürlich fast unmöglich. Zurückrudern, zurücknehmen. Das Zurücknehmen von Informationen das ist eigentlich die große mediale Kompetenz, die Forschung noch lernen muss.
Naja der Geist geht schnell aus der Flasche, aber man kriegt ihn nur sehr schlecht wieder rein.
Ja und deswegen kommunizieren viele auch nicht. Ich habe viele Kollegen, die sagen, nein ich halte mich da komplett raus. Und das ist nicht so sehr, weil sie keine Meinung haben. Die haben dezidierte und gute Meinungen. Das ist auch nicht so sehr, weil sie keine Kommunikationskompetenz haben, sondern weil sie Befürchtungen haben, was passiert eigentlich mit Informationen, wenn sie in der Welt sind?
Ja gut, aber die anderen haben da halt überhaupt gar keine Angst. Also es wird sozusagen im Bereich Gegeninformationen – haben Sie ja vorhin auch schon angedeutet nicht wahr, also wenn man jetzt sozusagen nach Webseiten sucht, die sich aktiv für die Stützung der These der flachen Erde oder anderen Beklopptheiten macht, dann kriegt man die Tür nicht zu und sagen wir mal, der gepflegte Geist, der alles gerne fünfmal durchdenkt und sich gut überlegt, bevor da irgendwas wirklich auch mal final geschrieben ist, naja der hält sich dann halt zurück und man hat dann irgendwann auch mal was treffendes vielleicht in der Wikipedia und ein paar veröffentlichte Studien. Und dem steht halt dieser Wildwuchs, diese pure Quantität und natürlich auch damit gepaart diese Radikalität, die ja auch teilweise sagen wir mal auf gebildete Menschen so absurd wirkt, weil es einfach vollkommen meistens auch zusammenhangloses Geschreibsel ist.
Was aber dann eben trotzdem seinen eigenen Netzwerkeffekt erzielt, dass Leute sich sozusagen immer wieder gegenseitig auf irgendwas beziehen und sagen, hier da steht das doch.
Na ich habe halt Einbahnstraßenkommunikation. Was das Netz mir bietet ist das was ich in meinem Seminar nicht habe. Also wenn ich jetzt eine Wutbürgerin oder ein Wutbürger bin, das Netz ist optimal. Ich setze das ab. Ich setze die Wut da rein. Das ist ja auch hochgradig emotionaler Raum. Ich kann alles da absetzen. Ich kann im Grunde genommen jeden Konspirationsmythos der Welt finden. Ich kann den absetzen und dann ist der da und dann ist der weg. Und dann kommen vielleicht Gegenkommentare, die kann ich aber ignorieren. Das kann ich natürlich in anderen kommunikativen Räumen überhaupt nicht.
Gut die Frage ist natürlich, muss das so bleiben?
Nein das wird nicht so bleiben.
Es wird nicht so blieben, okay. Darauf wollte ich eigentlich auch hinaus. Was wäre denn sozusagen eine wünschenswerte Änderung des Netzes? Sei es jetzt eine soziale oder vielleicht auch technische, die Sie als notwendig erachten würden für wissenschaftliche Arbeit als auch die gesellschaftliche Diskussion?
Eigentlich passiert jetzt gerade etwas, was wir vor zehn Jahren gefordert haben. Ich habe auch viel zusammengearbeitet mit der Amadeu-Antonio-Stiftung, das ist eine NGO, die den Bereich Rechtsextremismus, Populismus und so weiter Projekte durchführt und auch Projekte fördert,  vor allen Dingen da, wo keine Förderung ist. Und wir haben vor zehn Jahren uns über das Thema Netz, Extremismus im Netz aber auch Hatespeech und so weiter. Und da war unser großes Problem, Hass wird abgesetzt, es werden Menschen geschädigt. Also auch wenn per Twitter etwas über mich abgesetzt wird, gehe ich natürlich heute anders nach Hause. Also mein Leben ist heute sehr viel ungemütlicher als vor drei Jahren. Aber vor zehn Jahren haben wir darauf hingewiesen, dass man dort etwas tun muss. Da ist ganz wenig passiert, da ist überhaupt nichts passiert. Es hat keine Debatten, also nur im Bereich der Haltespeech-Forschung.
Und dann in Amerika, in Amerika aber auch immer, weil es immer ein Versicherungsfall ist. Wenn in Amerika irgendwie, das ist eine andere Kultur. Ich bin gespannt, ob das hier eine Kultur wird. Also wenn das bei uns eine reine Versicherungskultur ist, ich finde Hatespeech im Netz gegen mich und dann habe ich die Möglichkeit, dort hohe Summen einzuklagen, dann haben wir eine ganz andere gesellschaftliche Dynamik. Das haben wir hier nicht, weil wir sagen, Diskriminierungsphänomene sind nicht nur rein individuelle Phänomene, sondern betreffen immer die ganze Gemeinschaft. In Amerika ist individualistisches Versicherungsrecht. Hochgradig interessant, mal gucken, ob das Modell kommt. Aber wir haben das gesagt und dann hatten wir nun, das ist immer so, diese massiven Straftaten im öffentlichen Raum. Pegida, danach Wiedererstarken von Extremismus, Rechtsextremismus, viele Straftaten, viele Kriminaldelikte und so weiter. Und das richtete auf einmal die Aufmerksamkeit auf diesen massiven Hass, der im Netz schon war.
Und der dort abgesetzt wird und das ist 14/15 im Jahreswechsel gewesen, da kam das Thema auf. Und was ist dann passiert in einer unheimlichen Geschwindigkeit? Erst haben Medien, die im Netz unterwegs sind, alle Kommentare immer geöffnet und die Idee gehabt, dass die Öffnung für alle ja auch einen Teil von Meinungsfreiheit und demokratischer Kultur ist und dann ist wahnsinnig schnell der Gesellschaft klar geworden, dass hier auch Menschen verfolgt werden. Dass dieser Hatespeech nicht nur einfach eine Wut ist. Also ich habe überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass jemand im Netz schreibt, der Zick ist ein Idiot. Aber wenn jemand im Netz dazu aufruft, verfolgt ihn.
Dann wird es schwierig.
Dann wird es schwierig und das hat man gesehen. Und was ist dann passiert? Dann haben tatsächlich die digitalen Medien darauf reagiert und haben Kommentarleisten zum Teil geschlossen, das ist die eine Bewegung. Oder aber, und das war die notwendige Bewegung, sie haben Mediatoren und Moderatoren dort eingesetzt. Das heißt wir haben in der Facebook Kommunikation, wir haben bei den Kommentarseiten, bei Unternehmen, die sich das leisten können, nun mittlerweile eine mediierte und moderierte Kommunikation. Also das ist ja jetzt bekannt, dass bei der Tagesschau dort Leute sitzen, die in den Kommentaren die verfolgen und dort mediieren und moderieren. Ich bin auch selbst mal gefragt worden von der Zeit, ob ich da bei einem Artikel, den ich geschrieben habe, dort mitmache und so weiter. Und das ist eigentlich der Weg. Das heißt diese digitalen Medien werden eigene Interaktions- und Kommunikationsräume, wo wir als Akteure auftreten, wie in der analogen Welt. Und das wird sich so entwickeln.
Das mag dann sein, dass ich zunehmend auch eben digital kommuniziere über unsere Forschungsthemen und überhaupt nicht mehr analog. Und dazu brauche ich aber Mediation und Moderation, wenn es um Streitfälle geht, wenn es um Konfliktkommunikation geht brauche ich das. Wir haben in vielen internationalen, auch in den Forschungen in Instituten, wenn Forschungsprojekte entwickelt werden, greifen wir zunehmend auf Unternehmen, die Kommunikation organisieren, zurück. Weil die haben die Kompetenzen, diesen Dialog mit zu organisieren. Und das wird wahrscheinlich die Zukunft sein. Das entwickelt sich manchmal sehr schnell. Also es hat mich jetzt sehr gewundert, wie viele da doch dort diese Kommunikation mediieren und moderieren. Im Bereich von Hatespeech stehen wir auch über NGOs in Kontakt mit Google, Facebook und so weiter. Denen ist das Problem da gerade bekannt, auch wenn sie es unternehmerisch denken.
Weil es natürlich ein massiver Imageschaden ist, wenn dort Menschen geschädigt werden durch Kommunikation. Es könnte noch viel mehr sein. Denn wir haben ja Forschungsbereiche, die uns schon lange vorgeführt haben, wie schädigend Internetkommunikation sei. Entweder denken wir da in dem Bereich an Mobbing und Bullying, das ist auch zunehmend digitale Gewalt geworden. Und dann denke ich geht es wahrscheinlich wie die ganze Diskussion, was ist gute Arbeit, müsste man eine Diskussion führen, was ist ein gutes Netz. Wir haben ja Bereiche, wo wir diskutieren Work-Life-Balance, und das könnte man natürlich auch diskutieren über Digital und Analog Life Balance.
Das wird ja auch getan. Um das vielleicht mal so ein bisschen zusammenzurollen, wenn ich das richtig raus gehört habe. Ich glaube der Begriff Medienkompetenz wandelt sich.
Ich glaube der ist irreführend, also der wird irreführend sein, da habe ich große Befürchtungen, weil wir im Bereich der Bildung, wenn wir mal angucken Bologna-Prozess, europäischer Kompetenzkatalog. Also das ist ganz interessant, BA-, MA-Studiengänge und so weiter, Bologna wird diskutiert. Da wird diskutiert, wir machen die Bildung über die Vermittlung von Kompetenzen. Daraus könnte es passieren in einer sehr ökonomisch orientierten und auf Indikatorisierung hinauslaufenden Welt, dass wir dann anfangen, für Kompetenz Indikatorensysteme zu entwickeln. Also ich weiß nicht, ob der Kompetenzbegriff nicht dazu führt, dass wir demnächst Indikatoren haben für, wann ist jemand medienkompetent oder wann ist jemand nicht medienkompetent.
In dem Kontext wollte ich das jetzt so gar nicht definieren, sondern eher sagen wir mal Medienkompetenz auch so ein bisschen als Kampfbegriff auch so der digitalen Elite schon seit der 90er Jahre, die das ja eigentlich von der Gesellschaft immer eingefordert hat. Und sicherlich war bisher Medienkompetenz immer sehr viel mehr darauf bezogen worden, wie gehe ich überhaupt erst mal um, kann ich einen Browser bedienen, kann ich posten, kann ich dieses kann ich jenes tun und jetzt stellen wir auf einmal fest, oh holla, die Gesellschaft verlagert sich auch ins Netz bzw. ist da im selben Maße und teilweise noch stärker präsent, weil wir eben auch diese regionalen Strukturen natürlich mittelfristig auflösen. Leute, die sich einmal jetzt in diese Diskussion mit einklinken, im Guten wie im Schlechten, und man ist mit dieser ganzen Kommentarkultur und der ganzen Onlinediskussion erst mal total überfordert. Weil es ja im Prinzip ein Diskussionsstrang ist, der teilweise so gar nicht existiert hat oder sich zumindest in ganz anderen Gepflogenheiten und ganz anderen sozialen Kontrollsituationen abgespielt hat.
Und jetzt muss das aber aufgenommen werden. Jetzt ist es sozusagen Teil eben dieser Medienkompetenz, nur um mal bei dem Begriff zu bleiben. Sprich es muss erlernt werden und ich habe so den Eindruck, es muss halt vor allem auch naja von der Elite, die sich bisher recht wohl gefühlt hat mit dem Status quo, die jetzt aber zunehmend verstört auf die Ist-Situation blickt, aufgenommen werden. Weil wenn das nicht gemacht wird, kann dieser freilaufenden Diskussion auch nichts entgegengesetzt werden.
Absolut, bin ich vollkommen bei Ihnen. Und wenn es nur elitäres Verständnis von Medienkompetenz wäre falsch. Sie haben das ja genau richtig beschrieben. Ich glaube es ist kommunikative Kompetenz, die erreicht uns, die erwischt uns. Was machen wir in Vorlesungen, wenn keiner mehr kommt? Bei uns, wir haben keine Anwesenheitskontrolle mehr, aber digital würde man teilhaben. Studierende wollen digital teilhaben. Das ist dann auch in unserer Verantwortung, das bereitzustellen, was bedeutet das eigentlich? Reicht das, wenn ich vorne da stehe und hinten laufen die Folien ab, weil jetzt gerade die Kamera so eingerichtet ist? Oder muss ich nicht eigentlich dem Medienzentrum sagen, nein ich kann nur kommunizieren, wenn ich herumlaufe und dann müsst ihr dafür sorgen, dass ich beim Rumlaufen auch gefilmt werden kann. Oder es reicht auch meine Folien zu sehen. Das sind Sachen, kommunikative Kompetenz bedeutet in unseren Bereichen, wenn Medien bedeutsam sind, für uns sind zum Teil zum Beispiel Medien bedeutsam, weil sie an Orten sein können, wo wir nicht sind.
Ich bin immer froh, wenn ich Kontakt habe zu Journalistinnen und Journalisten, wo keine Universitäten und Wissenschaftler mehr sind, in gewaltaffinen Regionen. Also ich bin froh, wenn ich einen Kollegen kenne, der in Idomenie in einem Flüchtlingslager ist und dort eine Reportage macht und ich Kontakt genau zu diesem Medienmacher habe und er mir berichten kann. Das ist ein ungeheures Wissen. Und da brauche ich dann eine kommunikative Kompetenz. Der verlangt von mir aber dann das ich Tit-For-Tat auch bereit bin, mit ihm zu reden, nicht in diesem Luxusformat, wie wir es gerade haben, sondern in drei Minuten. Das ist ja ein reziprokes Verhältnis. Ich glaube man muss sich über Reziprozität nochmal unterhalten. Also ich bin da aber ganz hoffnungsvoll, denn wir haben eine leidvolle Diskussion an den Universitäten geführt über diese Frage Präsenz.
Nicht uninteressant. Also was bedeutet eigentlich Lernen, Lernen vor Ort. Anwesend sein in Veranstaltungen und so weiter.
Mit Reziprozität beziehen Sie sich auf den soziologischen Begriff, das Prinzip der Gegenseitigkeit?
Genau und das ist ja der Kommunikationsprozess. Das heißt, wir sind ja in der Wissenschaft ein bisschen dazu verleitet, immer in eine Richtung zu kommunizieren, nämlich andere mit unseren Erkenntnissen zu besprechen. Aber es verändert sich. Digitale Gesellschaft heißt, die Reaktionen sind sehr viel schneller. Sehr viel schneller und der Widerspruch ist sehr viel schneller. Das ist ja auch das was wir erfahren im Netz. Im Netz ist der Widerspruch so hoch.
Ja es wird Zeit für mehr und neue digitale Kompetenz. An der Stelle würde ich auch gern nochmal auf Forschergeist 22 verweisen, das Gespräch mit Jürgen Handke, auch von der Universität Marburg, wo Sie ja auch waren, was schöne Perspektiven gezeigt hat, wie das in der Lehre untergebracht werden kann, aber hier sind wir uns zumindest einig, es muss halt auch ein anderer Umgang mit der Öffentlichkeit stattfinden und das muss sozusagen einfach aufgenommen werden. Ja Herr Zick super.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nicht zu viel geredet, aber das Format hier verleitet ja dazu.
Wir gehen her in die Breite.
Mal länger den Standpunkt.
Gedanken müssen auch ein wenig umher getragen werden.
Ja wunderbar. Das ist zum Beispiel etwas was in der Medienwelt ich bitterlich vermisse. Also wir haben ja in den letzten Jahren eine Einschränkung da erfahren, auch im Bereich von Journalismus. Ich saß in manchen Sendungen, wo wir sehr viel Zeit haben, jetzt haben wir weniger Zeit zu sprechen, weil Einspieler, Bilder dazukommen und so weiter. Also der Zeitraum Forschung zu vermitteln ist jetzt, was so die etablierten Medien betrifft, ja enger geworden. Das heißt wir müssen jetzt die Kompetenz besitzen, in noch weniger Zeit noch viel komplexere Sachverhalte zu erklären. Nicht einfach.
Und deswegen gibt es Podcasts, die tragen auch zur Weltrettung bei. So nochmal vielen Dank.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören an alle, die hier immer wieder bei Forschergeist reinhören. Hier geht es bald wieder weiter, aber für heute war es das erst mal, ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.
Ich danke auch.